bake me back
yes all that beef in the street yeah
yeah what are you doing
all that meat on the table wow
make sure the levels is good make sure
the levels is good no doubt they're
running around throwing beef around Paul
yeah check that check the YouTubes check
the YouTubes see if the YouTubes is back
looks look good on my side yeah we look
good we looking good you know so I still
gotta y'all put me to work on my day off
coming in from sunny California let me
get this little thing
yeah that's true too
the cool cool cool all right part one
part two yeah we'll just do a part one
part two kind of energy all right got
super chat popping all right you know
welcome and all that
oh yo like the attic version y'all like
that huh oh oh yeah yeah so what I like
that version I like the attic version
you're welcome to get us to the intro so
I can be out here by three oh wow yeah
that definitely happens
Welcome Back to the Island podcast LLC
live or Lords gaming.net episode number
317 and today we've got the Lord's
returning and I'm freestyling off the
top of this because we definitely
flowing we've got Gamescom and
predictions and Starfield bald is gate
three switch to rumors and Transformers
games to discuss so we gonna get right
into it so let's introduce the Four
Horsemen of Gamers original Knights of
the realm here at the round table my
co-host with the cold Mouse I'm running
from another mother difficult game
conquer a lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf back to back
holding me down my man Lord attic how
are we doing sir going on guys uh yo
sorry about that I don't know what
happened I I think like
I've never seen that because I didn't
touch that I was just like oh I'm gonna
get together she usually it'll be like
issues but it just it just straight up
just into the stream it could handle the
bandwidth yeah we got to figure out that
is scary though even when stuff like
that's happened in the past it's like
self-corrected it's never just yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that might have been a YouTube thing I
mean YouTube he was playing Baldur's
Gate and all that yeah I've been playing
I I have like 20 hours 25 you said 25
don't shave
so what stitched the other join in and
of course we got our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sostradamus the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
The Rock Ally was listening on the way
in uh issues I heard issues issues not
not that not the Allies fault but like I
said I finished Resident Evil remake and
I I enjoyed it oh I got to I got to a
super chat in a minute they said like
re2 remake is better and I yes I agree I
agree but this is this is still a great
remake and it's a great way to bring
that game forward because uh there's
still there's a little bit of clunkiness
to the old school re4 so gotcha um but
yeah I was trying to get jump into my
next game which is going to be Alan Wake
remastered so I'm getting ready for Alan
Wake two and as it turns out the PC Port
is got bad
and uh so even on uh regular rigs like
it doesn't run super well and on the
Rock in particular it crashes to desktop
like 10 seconds in after as soon as you
start gameplay you know the beginning of
Alan Wake for is you you you're you're
driving you hit somebody you get out of
the car and then the gameplay starts I I
walk down the block and it's a wrap
right so uh I I think it's having to do
something with like a memory leak or
something like that where it's just like
it's using way too much uh CPU
um so I've heard you can go into like
the config files and delete them and
that helps it but I I don't know we'll
see if not I'll just play it on my
series X and that's about it I'm trying
to figure out what's the next thing I'll
play on the Rock then it's not going to
give me issues
to show the controller again you you
avoiding you avoiding games that's your
PC camera
shoot game it and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
the profit of Xbox one king of the
statues which demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the whole the line movement
beloved Lord King I heard you was
talking about controllers when I was
driving it I'm doing a whole lot better
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so shout out to um hex gaming
uh they send me the the Tactical gaming
controller
um so I think Addie's gonna cut the
other yeah but um so it comes in this
box and comes in the cardboard we know
how you feel about the presentation
though
um and
comes with the styrofoam and in here it
says you'll find your thumb sticks in
here with a little bit
look inside here put fries inside
like the crack of Jack digging the
bottom of the crack of dick
and then you get this so if you're old
enough to know about the Cracker Jack
box this is inside and this is your um
thumbstick so the converse and um convex
and um concave and they're longer as far
as height goes and shorter I game with
the um
shorter tactical controller oh that
looks fine look at it go this this one I
made uh and it's a one of one I don't
believe anybody has this control that's
very kick David that is they have so
many different options when you're going
to make the controller the biggest
feature that I found so far is the remap
button uh you hold this down and you can
remap all your buttons uh and it's it's
just it's a game changer it has the the
text paddles yeah like that okay right
and they're different from paddles these
buttons are actual buttons that are in
the back that you know you get a chance
to just
right and there's not three of them on
each side it's just two what's that
little button underneath the battery
pack there's like a little circular
button oh that's the remap button oh the
rematch okay got you guys so and also
inside the the you know the Box you get
the instructions and you like why would
I get instructions with a controller
well it gives you
the remap stuff it tells you about your
um your buttons in the back it tells you
how to put your thumb sticks in and you
know it's it's I mean I I like
information like that I don't like to
you know do a scan a little bar thing
and then you you know yeah talk to a
website or whatever I like stuff like
this I mean this stuff um makes makes
the purchase feel a little bit more
premium to me
um and then you have a six month
warranty a six month warranty uh from
data purchase is it's kind of dope
because you want a peace of mind when
you pay a premium dollar for a
controller or anything in life and you
know and they tell you stop you know
don't send it back to the store and you
know come to us and we'll you know work
it out with you so
the controller has uh tactiles here for
the grips down at the bottom and it's
non-slip you can feel it I put this
controller through so many games
um I put it through his spaces so out
when car got here I got a chance to
remember a couple of the games I played
like Celeste inside uh Game Pass and
Serious Sam that I played as well along
with fortnite Street Fighter Mortal
Kombat and Killer Instinct now a lot of
times the d-pads and uh controllers suck
this d-pad
very Twitchy very delicious good good
look at it yeah they go so what are we
feeling for I'm sorry I was gonna ask
you how you feel it for the fighting
games though
it felt perfect like
um I was playing Street Fighter I got my
wins in Street Fighter small combat I
was able to pull off my moves
um you know it's it's definitely
a game changer like the buttons are
Snappy okay like if you if you can hear
that like the thumb sticks don't stick
they're Snappy and I know a lot of times
they're gonna say well you know usually
on a new controller I mean the triggers
don't stick well
um it does have some perceived latency
on some controllers right this is really
Snappy like with the buttons really
Snappy uh thumbsticks really Snappy
everything
feels like it's just ready to rock this
controller is ready to rock so you know
of course when I'm playing fortnite
I'm going to put it through its paces
and we got into a lot of intense matches
and I never felt like the controller was
holding me back I remapped a couple of
buttons that was in the back so I can
just you know drink my slurp juices a
whole lot faster and it just it helped
overall right I'm I'm always looking for
an edge especially in a game that you
know you you you're playing
um a game that's gonna come down to
milliseconds it's always going to end up
with you versus somebody else of course
and when when when
when
you are versus somebody else you want a
tactical advantage and I think that you
know the hex gaming tactical controller
gives you that Advantage now
it's a little bit pricey but it's in the
ballpark of custom controllers and I
believe that they have a larger more
robust custom controller setup than any
other people that I did see before so
their controller set up as far as
putting stuff together attic and I sat
there meticulously put a lot of stuff
together it's so many different things
that you can do on this controller like
in here that red part it didn't have to
be red I made it or you can put you
could oh so they bought more
customizable than like the um the elite
stuff to the the buttons in the back
yeah so you can use every aspect of it
not just the colors on the face type
every aspect of this controller is
customizable and that's what sets it up
apart from other controllers I mean
you're going to somebody's going to come
to your house and they're going to see a
one of one and they're going to say
where can I get that controller you can
go to the website and try to you know
make it but um it's not going to be the
same it's some somebody's always going
to do a little bit different to their
controller got you this controller
speaks to me and
um I was going through all the designs
and they have a lot of designs there but
the Egyptian Motif is something that you
know Mary did to me and I saw it and I
immediately knew that this was right now
this is for the series x and x and I I
tried on both I played the game on Play
Games on both uh consoles with this
controller and I didn't see any
perceived latency or anything like that
I checked for dead zones I didn't find
any dead zones when I was playing so I'm
not really a tactician I didn't put it
up to a computer and you know
but I got you it it did uh allow me like
I tried certain techniques that I saw
before with moving really slow and if
the controller doesn't move that's a
dead zone
um so I looked that stuff up on YouTube
before I did it I didn't I didn't find
any uh I'm not gonna say that there's
none there but if there is it's very
miniscule but this controller performs
now it's light it's not as heavy as uh
an elite but it's slightly heavier than
the regular stock controller gotcha so
if you have the end
um you can remove the rumble out of it
if you want to get lighter than the
regular stock controller this things
this controller can be customized to any
way you want a game if you want to save
battery power you want to do whatever
you want to do this controller is
definitely made for you now what I would
say at hex games is if I had to rate the
controller I'm going to rate the
controller a four out of five because of
the shipping box uh I think when you pay
premium prices you should get a clam
shell to put it yeah yeah Lee got that
nice
because this if if this is a one-on-one
you want to put it on a stand let's see
yeah yeah so
um it's the same way I felt with the Rog
they gave you a little plastic thing to
put your raw game and stand up I was
just like that kind of turned me off
yeah
that was disgusting all right that's
horrible okay other than that the
controller is top-notch Top Flight I
definitely recommend it to everybody
that's in um in the market looking for a
premium controller I didn't get a chance
to use the PlayStation 5 controller so
uh hex gaming uh send me a PlayStation 5
controller so I can put that through its
Paces so I can actually finish God of
War Ragnarok I got over there
you can't finish it without it it's
ridiculous it gives me a reason to go
over there you know I didn't need a
reason to go over there and play the hex
controller is the reason the same reason
why uh assault is running away from
games on his Rock
um I can't play it
I can't play without a new controller so
send me a new controller so I can go
over there yes let him play his
PlayStation so yeah please say but
definitely worth the um the weight uh
attic and I was like checking the mail
Alex like did he get there yet did he
get there you know when it got there I
did the unboxing live on Twitter
um I went live yesterday shout out to
everybody that came through with combat
talk uh we had uh Jake versus Nate yeah
so I saw the maturity of Jake come
through uh shout out to everybody that
you know super chatted you know cash
after whatever
um and just retweet it so like if you
can't you know send anything it's cool I
don't care just retweet share it out let
somebody else see it let somebody else
who's at work let's say you got a friend
that's a security guard or somebody that
has to do an overnight at a warehouse or
whatever who doesn't have access to be
around his friends well I'm gonna keep
you company and we're going to talk
fights and we're going to have a good
time uh we talked a whole bunch of
things we talked while wrestling we
talked about cameras
oh sorry talk about wrestling we talk
about football uh we talked about a
whole bunch of things but uh again at
the same time we had a great time so uh
shout out to everybody that did come
through had a great time and I
appreciate everybody that pulled up
everybody has shared it out thank you
again and um combat talking Saturdays at
10 p.m live on Twitter you know lemon
reached out to me and was like yo send
me the link um like uh it's on Twitter
saluted by the way hit me up I had to
get my new uh my new Galaxy it ain't
come yet but that dude yeah he's like um
so are you on Spaces I'm like no I'm
live on Twitter or X you're an act sir
you're there oh excuse me yeah you play
Elon Elon in the X exactly oh you
PlayStation dudes y'all on x
see what you're doing is that video yeah
that's it you know having fun you know
on X I see and of course we have the gay
videos of this [__] that will be look
Cognito spread that Rose to the Roman
IOP not tell you what you want to hear
but what you need here shout out to
every single person that pulled up on me
to gcx it was so much fun the community
is super dope last word got together
mine is Travis but he bought just pulled
up the the Leviathan you know it's one
of the best venues in gaming as far as
like it's literally a resort it's a golf
course it's everything it's all you
never have to leave the premises it's
beautiful
um yeah shot everybody they pulled up
bungee pulled up in forces I see back
for dead up in there no doubt salute
salute level one game when I see you
what's going on yeah man Orlando but I
would say that heat different that heat
different different and then they had
they had the nerve to be like yes we're
gonna go to Universal Studios afterwards
on a Sunday I mean on a Saturday you
know and I'm like all right that sounds
cool you know when you're not built for
amusement parks no more you're not built
for walking online
but the cool thing is we had a wristband
that go off at nine o'clock and you kick
all the plebs out we had a whole talk to
us what I guess he got the little joints
because like yes I'll I'll turn my oils
like remove thyself from the premises
this is gcx territory kids so you get to
you get the shack the park a little bit
wow yeah it was fun that part was fun
the parts that was not fun was I got a
universe like I said on the over joint I
gotta come for you I got wild disappear
I got my Transformer shirt on yeah out
here selling the death to Optimus Prime
action figure talking about Fallen
Autobot leader greyed out with the
Matrix bro we not doing that we're not
doing it right now cease and desist on
that that's wild disrespectful I've
never seen no cartoon no major character
in the history of toys and Anime talk
about by The Death of Superman by his
corpse they talk about action figure
what yeah yeah they wild and they watch
so that I was wild I couldn't believe it
but I will say they had the little
Transformers movie section you can have
the Megatron and all of that the journey
for the movie the Michael Bay former
joint but yeah other than that um yeah
it was good it was rocked out as far as
games playing the Ally I play a lot of
Ghost Fire Tokyo on the um on the plane
was getting that I really ran really
well getting the high 50s close to 60
frames battery was that was not holding
up though the battery that battery on
that flight boy I was connected to that
battery pack so yeah that was that I
gotta I gotta find out what battery pack
that is that keeps you at the 30 Watts
yeah that's it I'm right now I'm
blocking this drug called it's an omni
charge you know what I'm saying it's
crazy but yeah I'll talk about that but
I mean other than that same old stuff um
again shout out to everyone that pulled
up for last word everyone put up for IOP
to find and do LSM the whole fam and uh
yeah it's been it we're gonna get the
super chats get into the polls and all
this game yes sir yes sir I actually
have the super attached from part one of
today's podcast so I'm gonna go with
that first got Robert Kelly at five
dollars Super Chat blessed Sunday Lords
damn shame little man isn't packing
enough meat to play bt3
wow people missing out on fun times with
bears and lizards wow
well we'll talk about that you know
that's coming up when we get to that
we're gonna get to that then we have
normal people five dollars we can chat
Microsoft needs to dive into the Scrooge
McDuck Vault and give Larry in the back
to put bg3 on Game Pass to assert its
dominance push the line much love y'all
don't talk about Microsoft buying
anything
there they came for you how dare you
that's the one of the very few times
I've seen Xbox PlayStation and PC people
come together and say screw at it it was
a unified front against you it was it
was man oh man I I I held the LIE
those thumbnail titles
rocking that algorithm too hard they not
feeling there
they increased the the engagement on my
Twitter tenfold man it was like 157
000. that is that that is the desired
results
oh we click mating oh man here we go
what else we got then we got Robert
Kelly again 2010. how will Survivor run
on PS4 540p to 20 frames per second yeah
probably yeah I don't know how they
doing this why they do it's not even red
like they're they're developing it now
so I don't know whatever yo is that room
and true the the camera uh
yeah getting stripped down interesting
then we have Pat F two dollars which
have blessed Sunday to all here and the
IOP realm you as well so absolutely
Robert Kelly once again two dollars
Super Chat damn this is a lean day huh
no beef the beef is here the beef is all
right here now
we have it Lieutenant Hulk go ahead at
it yeah
no it was too much wow you caught
yourself from being that [__] he's gonna
cross the line
Lieutenant Hulk five dollar Super Chat
sup Lords let's talk about Xbox not
promoting Starfield according to the
other side of the fence I guess we're
gonna talk about that then we have
Doctor Strange Love two dollar Super
Chat re4 and his remake suck overrated
re2 is better ra2 is better I like re4
though but I like I said it's hard for
me to process my full thoughts on it
because I played it in such broken up
chunks but overall I like it
um then we have stay high FFF five
dollars
they're very lifted Sunday elevated
shout out to the Lord's King thanks
again for the show last night pause I
remember I said I was gonna hit you up
today yeah really and yeah where'd be
that
[Laughter]
yeah you might want to restart probably
like another application is trying to
access your camera access it yeah yeah
that's what it is who's touching me
we have black Road in 357 remember for
18 months Lord silver what up Lords
playing Remnant 2 and listening to the
best gaming podcast crew who keeps it
100 it's Baldo's Gate 3 holding the line
it's holding the line apparently a nice
93-94 Metacritic line killing it out
here
then we have Pat F let's put the crest
in the chat for Pat f for gifting five
IOP memberships thank you I appreciate
that
then we got Tom from Toonami five dollar
Super Chat speaking of combat talk is
what I said before I wanna I wanna get
your take on this cargo speaking of
combat talk did King recap the Jose
Ramirez Tim Anderson
Well King yeah he didn't see it I talked
about it I saw it um but I was just like
they're bugging yeah
y'all are baseball players they get paid
too much to be getting knocked at each
other yeah I'm good y'all guys they'll
take off half the damn Year y'all don't
even it's it's the way that they get
down you stop it just just stop it y'all
fake man cut it out
continue yeah we got net watch two
dollars King what'd you think of the WWE
stripping Charlo
they didn't strip them yet when he gets
announced on September when he fights uh
Canelo he will be stripped you are not
going to go up there and fight for this
guy's uh unified title uh you know
Undisputed title and go up there with
your Undisputed that's just not how it
happens WBO said we're not part of this
circus uh you can go up there and fight
and we're gonna give this belt to Tim
zoo and Tim zoo is going to go fight
somebody else so if anybody want to get
over there like Earl Spence or you know
Crawford to fight Tim Zoo to go for that
WBO belt and then those other belts is
going to be up for grabs because those
dudes is going up to 154. that is
happening but
um nobody can cry foul this guy is going
up and chasing Big Dreams he's won the
fight Canelo at you know 168 and if he
beats Canelo um he becomes Undisputed at
168 and he gets all the glory so yeah
strip him so what who cares he doesn't
care about those belts he's moving up
anyway I don't know you can't maybe try
leave the zoo if it still doesn't try to
leave Zoom come back and maybe see if
that works and worst case restart if not
but right now you seem good no I keep
clicking it oh every time just delete it
come back see if it came back but it's I
am I'm checking the stuff
it could be it could be the base like
your like Logitech or something trying
to take control of the camera for
whatever whatever reason
um Tom from Toonami 2002 which at Old
Wendy's commercial where's the beef
shout out to the old lady
rip yeah that's a classic
then we have Dr Strangelove two dollars
for chat I got beef withdrawals the
entire time
then we have Danny passion official the
two dollar Super Chat we're buffering
today hello Chad hit the like at the
bottom of the chat thank you so much
appreciate that
then we have nobody five dollars
so guys the news that Killer Instinct is
back how are you feeling and also James
Goddard is head of Killer Instinct hmm
hey guys back yeah that is interesting a
lot of a lot of ones on Galaxy talk look
at things and cook it I see Jason right
over tweeting stuff yeah something could
get a 4K update that's very nice you
gotta see that's a big deal looks good
man I like that game looks beautiful you
can look as good as I want to do it when
they first came out it was dope then
they did a bunch of hunky stuff to it
Jesus
it was just ridiculously weird so I'm
just like no yeah
it plays great I'm not saying it doesn't
I'm just saying they did a whole bunch
of stuff to it that no
um
the um all right so like they built some
little fake story around it and they
drop you down in like little pods and
little monsters is popping up all over
the world and then you gotta fight these
guys
what you're saying to me I don't even
recall so I know you don't I need to go
back and play see I was playing real
real hard at hard and heavy pulse when
it first came out on it then they did
some update and I was like what's this
little Global update thing and then the
around the world spots is happening I'm
like what is this stupid thing
I'm like you just went away from the
good story and gave us the old school
okay I got it yeah this is a good story
you saw Namco right you don't got to
reinvent the wheels let's get a story
behind everybody just put it on just
what it came out I'm just glad they're
not leaving it for dead that's my thing
because before this thing looked like it
was never coming back like it was like
taboo to talk about it like no one was
gonna do it so to me at least updating
it like is it going to be a Killer
Instinct uh whatever they're gonna call
it something's going on because one of
the guys I think is on LinkedIn with
like unannounced project that was like
working on it looks like there's
something cooking there's definitely we
just don't know to the the full extent
whether it's just gonna update the
existing game and that's it or they
updated existing game to set up maybe
the potential no when you got Street
Fighter six out there
and you got Mortal Kombat coming out if
you don't step your game up bro like do
not give me a update to that same weak
game do not do that it's nice it's
nostalgic haha so yo game up I feel like
they'll do an update and maybe release
one character to like gauge interest in
the brand but I I do think because if
you're just gonna do an update you could
have just had the Xbox Studio do the
update 4K pastures there's plenty of
people that could have done this like
you brought iron Galaxy an entire Studio
back to work on Killer Instinct it's
more than just an update man we got uh
10-year anniversary update 4K 4K series
support updated matchmaking and server
updates yeah I would say with in a year
year and a half a Killer Instinct two
will be yeah I think it's Gage interest
you gotta you gotta build it's been dead
full of key out of pocket like it's
Gotta Do
it he does really really disgusting he
really was disgusted
don't dip your toe in the water if you
didn't get in the shower get in the
shower but there was no water an hour
ago exactly nobody was even paying the
bill and exactly you think somebody's
gonna tell care that you put a new soap
bar inside the shower oh it's a new soap
in the corner I don't care about that
soap
but like the K megas is too eyes opinion
I care about when it comes to you don't
care about mine
I've never heard you even talk about it
YouTube channels on that all you gotta
do is go on my timeline I'll smoke a
[__]
that sounds like a challenge
so so
it was crazy man you know
I see comments weekly about me
interrupting people but I never see
comments about King bro but hold up you
can't ask is this this this part of the
game to disgusts you so it it are you
forced to play that part
[Laughter]
[Music]
stream so beefy that little man couldn't
take it yo
[Laughter]
working on the final touches y'all gonna
like it
let's go
then we got uh the death trap for the 40
rupees uh I believe Cognito broke the
stream with his beefiness
[Music]
two dollars out of pocket right now Sam
looks like the beef has oh enter
don't get put on with the answer whoa
whoa music please
like there was a pause yeah like he's
doing that one through
Back To You song I was extra extra wow
welcome back brother salute to The Realm
by the way uh Ballers Gate 3 is indeed
an addiction waiting to happen if you
have a PCA want to play Starfield don't
do it
yeah it's one of them things yeah
then we got uh nobody who posted it
again we got to it thank you sir I
appreciate you
uh then we got Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat selling Optimus without beef
damn yeah they did Optimus dirty that's
crazy I'm looking on your timeline I'm
trying to find it bro you gotta find
it's crazy just Google it I'm sure it
comes up man
then we got JD gave her five dollars of
attack good Sunday Lord how will the
community act after Microsoft ties up
its commitments and acquires both square
and Sega are we going to have a salty
day as long as addict don't do the title
it's all
there you go throw stones at him yeah
they don't even want me talking about
Microsoft buying something
it's the fear that it actually it can
happen and you know what it is they
don't like it because if I would have
made that video
four or five years ago no one would have
cared yeah but now that they buy an
Activision Blizzard this thing and
already bought Bethesda yeah wait hold
on yeah yeah look at that yard look at
this keep it on screen why is it called
an action figure if he is dead if it's
dead
why are they selling this fully better
questions how much beef can you put in
that chest oh this is if you want to
have you know you want to recreate the
diorama of that moment you know selling
yeah selling corpses decades
wow disrespectful I could have swung
back in the day I saw one with um with
Rodimus with hot rod like small hot rod
opening up the Matrix and then they had
different size hot rods growing into
Rodimus behind it moves like a statue
it's crazy
um yeah not this not death
I like how I like when he went back and
wrecked
happy Sunday my NYC West Virginia
cousins hello King thanks for a great
combat talk last night born and raised
in BK so sad to see that the nonsense
that took place at NYC yes did y'all see
this foolishness
yo did he actually give away any place I
don't know that it happened but I mean
at the end of the day
the bad the worst part about it is that
they got down there and started acting
stupid with like cabbies and like guys
that own new stands and stuff like that
stealing their stuff hitting them like
come on now well that's what's gonna
happen when you get 2 000 people in the
area you only got two PlayStations yeah
who did this
okay it's a YouTuber oh he's a streamer
he he's he's Transcendent he's you know
he's from the Bronx
um he's from the town uh highly
successful the guy is really I'm talking
about from the ground he built himself
he streams like all of February like the
whole February so he just was some
random I'm in New York pull up I got the
PlayStations type stuff I don't I don't
know how it went down because somebody
hit me when I was asleep and it was like
yo you okay the riots I'm like the right
right screamed it and told his community
that on Friday I'll be in Madison Square
Garden I guess that's what it's called
no it was uh Union Square
and I'm gonna have a bunch of
PlayStation 5S
New York type of time right yeah and he
said he was going to dedicate the
movement to getting people out of the
streets and having them straightened and
I think he definitely had good
intentions but when you have that kind
of following you can't be doing and
stuff like that so they was riding
that's crazy I look into it that's crazy
what else we got some
hey we had let me see the files
whoa whoa Halo Reach Around reach around
oh no it gets worse love how Lord
addicts spin in that chair while he
petting his Kitty yo place he could
he could hear the how oh the young wolf
yo
[__] that man was imagining where he
wanted to
I didn't know what are we going to do
with this
Halo reach around that's extra wow that
man said spit on the chair for him what
type of uh
subgroup or weed
y'all what y'all want to do lower beefy
right this is what you get this is what
you get that's what happened it's the
demographic week we in now yeah yeah you
like the beef you like it
[Applause]
that's right I forgot about that yeah oh
yeah oh yeah wow disrespectful there we
got JD gamer 2000 for chat all right
Galaxies for sure getting acquired
Killer Instinct versus MK
yeah that I will say you got to go back
to the drawing board yeah you gotta come
back something crazy
then we have booty remember for 24
months Lord bronze wagwan Lords on
beautiful Jamaican Independence Day no
respect
you're done no you're done no no no no
no
fire for them
there we got this turn down the attack
Super Chat iron Galaxy left Killer
Instinct to work on Rumble verse now
suddenly they are happy to work because
again I wonder why yeah Rumble versus
dead Rumble Wars is cool though it's
cool but
yeah I think they are owned by Amazon
but at the end of the day you know do
you want to talk about the killing
Instinct for the first topic because
like people I mean yeah we did kind of
just talk about it yeah yeah and we got
being messy because I just wanted to get
attic into a bra yeah all right
it's K Mega
[Music]
[Laughter]
I just love how you think you could be K
Mega and kill Instinct okay
why wouldn't I you want to see my
footage
[Laughter]
and then I'm gonna come right back to
you and say who's the greatest I would
have to say you at that point
[Music]
yeah I would thank you and I would say
thank you I mean you still ain't beat me
I will buy you a burrito
you already owe me your burrito
give me your burrito
here we have Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat cogbino clogging the stream
maybe we need joystick yo yo what what
has happened it's so left right now
iron Lord
that's what we are now we are edified
yes
then we have web Dave two dollars oh
hell the iron Lords everyone hit the
like shout out guys
the only salute Bread Dave
I knew bg3 was gonna be good but I
wasn't ready yeah
when we get to that topic
and we got let's play with each other's
joysticks two dollar Super Chat Halo
Reach Around is giving me ideas for
something
Jesus Christ you knew it was coming you
knew it was coming thank you for your
support
thank you for your patience
thank you Halo reach around and uh let's
play with each other's voices say first
are we good yeah yeah
last week poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question
regarding Final Fantasy 14 coming to
Xbox and the potential of future Final
Fantasy games coming to Xbox platforms
which do you anticipate happening first
very close poll four-way poll 34 of the
vote
octopath traveler two that was in first
place coming in at razor close second at
32 percent of was Final Fantasy remake
can't believe Final Fantasy loss that's
crazy in third place at 24 of the vote
was I don't care Phil about to put an
acquisition ring on Square Enix and then
last place at nine percent they like the
deficit was uh Final Fantasy 16 coming
to Xbox addict octopath tool you think
you think that's what was the right code
of the room
let's get into the topic solve you are
up I believe games come what's going on
stuff it was happening yeah we got
Gamescom coming up on August 23rd uh you
know we have Opening Night Live coming
up as well so you know Kelly always has
some surprises for us and we also know
that going into Gamescom that there will
be a Starfield theater presentation in
addition to a Forza theater presentation
yes
um in addition to maybe some of that
stuff being on the show floor right
Nintendo's gonna be there as well and
with certain leaks you never know maybe
maybe some information at the very least
it seems like maybe some conversations
isn't going to be had with other uh
Publishers and third-party Partners to
get their hands on uh some of that uh
hardware and that's it we know
PlayStation is not going to be there so
I I just want to see where you guys are
in terms of gamecom has not
traditionally been the place for the uh
you know secondary mic drop moments
right we know so but you never know and
with certain things leaking out maybe
some companies want to get out in front
of some messaging
um one thing that I saw that seriously
interested me and it came out a little
bit earlier I think it came out in July
was that the official Gamescom app
accidentally oh what they do showed
something for half-life
from valve interesting so hmm
PlayStation VR2 yeah you would think it
well no PlayStation presence maybe not
but you know maybe maybe Gabe learned
how to count to three I don't know I
doubt it
but we'll see that that's very
interesting to me right um because
Half-Life is something that just hasn't
since Alex we haven't seen anything they
haven't indicated they would ever plan
to go back and and kind of finish the
the trilogy or whatever the case may be
so that's interesting to me so I want to
know what you guys think about what
might be coming down the pipeline for
Gamescom cool attic what we thinking man
what's your predictions a lot of
presents they put out a big uh blog post
about a booth and all this stuff where
you at
I think it's about fan you know
attendance uh they want to make sure
people there that go there for the Xbox
brand have stuff to play you know I saw
a lot of people upset that you know
Starfield wasn't there I feel like you
could be disappointed but to like like
try to say something's wrong with the
game just because they're not at an
event that's four days before the game
comes out I think that's that's a little
bit of a reach I I don't expect too much
of this I expect maybe but is it a
reach-around
s you want that one or you want to be
the other one
hey hey hey
and now there's five back together
um you know I think it's just one of
those things where it's like look they
are going to
let you play these games you know we we
ain't really had too much Hands-On on
something like stalker yeah
what I find interesting is the from
software games going to be there on
their stage what's that about what are
we thinking we think about the marketing
I might think you're on a shot maybe if
they don't maybe the reason that
it's on their their floors because
PlayStation's not theirs if there's not
another stage to go on but to me it's
like if if PlayStation had the marketing
there's no way they would be okay with
their game being on their show I would
agree that's right so I think they got
the marketing for that it's interesting
we should say you know what comes to the
Starfield thing look if you're
frustrated that it's not going to be
there I get it but no demo the game
comes out four days later so at that
point what's the point but they do have
like a theater experience going on where
they show you stuff and you know I get
it but I understand why people are are
disappointed it's not there because
we've seen more gameplay but I just
don't understand how people are trying
to act like this is like bad news for
the game into the world and shout out to
Delilah she said why are people upset
the starfield's not there because
Spider-Man's not there either
I see what we do yeah there's a lot of a
lot of concern uh addicts everything
that's what they say they like concerns
they like no damage you know no
marketing the marketing is is not
concerning to me it's disappointing
because I feel like the game is good
it's just I don't understand why
Microsoft isn't marketing the game to
the to the degree that they should I
mean they have a I haven't seen one
commercial for Starfield now obviously
huh I said I've seen tons of them you've
seen commercials
it's cartoons like oh you talk about the
anime thing okay I feel you I feel you
on that but I don't I I don't feel like
that
is Justified marketing for a brand new
IP made by the developers that has made
multiple Game of the Year contenders or
game of the years it that that's what my
only thing it's like you know normally
I'm against traditional marketing but
for this particular title maybe you
should do a little bit of that you know
I want to see that chick from the from
the posters everywhere on billboards
everywhere now obviously when it comes
like YouTube advertising promoting I'm a
I'm a member of um
of YouTube premium so they might be
rolling you to uh you know
people in the chat if you've seen a star
filled
a Starfield commercial on YouTube tell
me because I'm very curious on that
because I had premium I don't see that
why you don't have premium I have broken
I have isn't this isn't this kind of
like par for the course for them though
like I kind of feel like you know with
Fallout 4 they announced it you know at
E3 or whatever and then they launched it
later that year and I don't even know
what they marketed a lot in between the
announcement and when it came out so I
don't mean Bethesda generally Skyrim a
lot but maybe bgs maybe BTS goes proper
just like yeah it was super close yeah
Skyrim was different Skyrim was was
further sort of out
um I don't know maybe that's kind of par
for the course for them and they don't
want to spoil anything
um I get it but at the same time you
would think that press starts needs to
start having this game already I would
agree I would agree I agree so it's got
to be out there right soon if I'm
talking about if not already next week
when you think about it or have a good
two to three weeks with the game before
and that that might not realistically
enough apparently Baldur's Gate 3 went
out like three or four days before the
game yeah like they didn't get it
anything yeah but here I'm sorry okay my
bad kid what'd you say no I said that
was a stadium
in Early Access for a long time and not
that that game didn't like just
transform after it hit 1.0 like it was
the same game so one thing we all forget
to know that looks like Starfield will
be there since attendees will be able to
check out exclusive theater
presentations of it of yourself so they
got to show it in some capacity just no
demo just no demoing yeah I'm okay with
that like I guess people because I'm not
going to Gamescom so that might be
disappointing on that front but I
looking at it doesn't feel like that is
something that's bad like oh you know
Starfield is in at Gamescom everyone
pack it up pack up the trucks we're not
we're not playing it game comes out four
days after Gamescom so at that point you
might might as well just wait four days
after game's gone shout out to boxing
Burger he said he's got a seat booked in
the star field and Forza theater present
test right Germany in the building
that's nice Fox but yeah you got to let
us know man y'all let us know how
concerned you are about that demo that
lack of demo now that's dope you're
gonna be up in the middle of the salute
so uh Lloyd King your thoughts on this
whole thing about the uh Gamescom your
little predictions which they gonna do
and then uh myself talk about about
Starfield well um the movie thing as far
as showing you know Starfield and Forza
um that's good I don't think uh
releasing Starfield as a playable demo
they will have to craft the demo yep uh
get that demo uh get that demo ready put
that demo uh through its Paces all this
other stuff you have to bug test the
demo do all this stuff just for Gamescom
all right so you get the game out the
Gamescom and then is it representative
of the whole game you know um RPG is
very hard to do in in that short period
of Time how long would that will be what
would the lines look like yeah
I think it made more headache than it uh
solved um any uh you know questions it's
a hard game to demo you would think yeah
that's a hard game to demo the only
thing I would like really think and I
don't even know if it would be enough to
satisfy people is like have a couple you
know chaos where you could jump on and
and just play around with the
customization of your character but if
you only offered people well these are
the options yeah they're gonna be bad oh
they hiding what can I play why can't I
play the game they not comfortable
showing right and then and then the
opposite you don't want to do making a
character you don't want to do a red
fall either and be like yeah it's a
vertical slice and it's very polished
just came off redfall too yeah so I just
want to say
um majority of this is the mustard heart
Xbox dude you have the mustard heart
Xbox dudes that's out here like a
mustard I need to I need to see it first
before I I buy it because my heart is
people not to be cautious they could be
as cautious as they want I Got Game Pass
I don't care
um you can have game pass too
um it's not exclusive to me so at the
same time the PlayStation dudes no
PlayStation ain't gonna be there so of
course they're gonna throw a battery in
the back of the mustard heart dude they
smack the battery in the back of the
mustard dude and say run go spread the
word that something's wrong with
Starfield and then you know the monster
heart dudes out in the street I think
something's wrong with Starfield they're
not showing it I think something's wrong
with Sony they're not there
think about that you can make that
argument definitely it's like and you
know what's funny Spider-Man would be an
easier game to have a demo for yeah it
would be an easier game lost Jim has not
been seen like Jim has turned into Waldo
I'm looking for Jim wherever we can find
Jim at we saw a site in the gym
someplace in Nebraska it was kind of
crazy
but listen
I I see what they're gonna do I don't
think anything great comes out of
Gamescom maybe some minor stuff nothing
crazy Gamescom has never been oh this is
where we're gonna release new stuff
usually what they do is whatever they
did for E3 with all the shows that they
had with the Bethesda shows they uh
streamline it and and get a nice little
package together and put it up for
Gamescom and it looks like a better
presentable package whatever they did
wrong
at E3 and uh the shows after E3 they
kind of clean it up for Gamescom gamecom
has a better presentation and I expect
that I expect Microsoft you know the
strut Day stuff knowing that in four
days after that Starfield will launch
and I believe that they know they have a
winner that's why they're going to give
you the the movie theater thing and the
forza I'm I'm more concerned
you know why isn't that playable why
isn't that there those little questions
that I have right so if they're going to
give you a trailer of Forza
um are you going to expound or are they
leaving it to turn 10 with the forza
events and allow them to present it on
their platform because you know Falls is
a huge thing to have a large community
so maybe they're allowing them to
present it to their audience that way
and then after that piggyback off of
that but I'm a little bit concerned with
Forza I've heard great things from
everybody everybody that's in the
background that I know of told me that
this is it this is the one this is the
thing and I'm like all right cool but
can I see it and they're like we send
out some pictures but um other than that
I I just think Microsoft is playing it
safe they're going to hold their cards
close to breast because Sony's not gonna
be there anyway don't need to flex for
no reason nothing I mean look this is a
big deal
um for them to actually say you know
we're gonna have a big presence at
Gamescom is pretty huge you know to see
them let's be honest like we go to pax's
either to see Xbox have a booth again is
a big deal you know what I mean and then
we talk about all these uh other times
that we're not even talking about 100
like 50 other titles we're talking also
like the stalker is going to actually be
there playable that's a good sign
because that that studio we know what's
going on in real life right with the
with the war and stuff like that and all
the terrible stuff that they had to
endure so to have them there to me that
seems like oh maybe they they'd be ready
hopefully at the top of 2024 or
something like that potentially that'll
be interesting um with the demo thing I
hear y'all I'm not gonna say that I
don't want demos but it's like King said
the reality is that cuts development
time you got to make a whole vertical
slice to sit there and then bug test a
half for a demo if a star feelings and
it doesn't even make sense exactly small
Philly makes absolutely no sense like
you're literally four days after the
show and it's gonna be in somebody house
like it literally makes your game I
prefer those people that would make that
um six months ago
work on the game yeah like and let's
let's be real right based on track
record and history and the complexity of
that game it kind of makes we would like
you to continue to work all the way
through
right so Forza should be there in some
way shape or form and some kind of
playable I get it I'm all about demos
I'm never gonna say no I just think like
there's two things I think that is
changing you know the the demo from
development cycles and then I also think
the marketing is changing I know you
know the homie kissing was in the cross
eye right now but like this is what I
think no idea
I already know I haven't paid attention
to the latest but I'll just go about
what I what I saw last week you know I
understand this concern listen I want
Starfield to be on of course poster
boards trains buses all I get it but we
also got to look at what's effective and
they may have the metrics look at what
we're about to talk about Baldur's Gate
right hey you know marketing football
this game do you see what it's doing it
just dropped and it's the viral the
reality of of people just say yo you
know it's good Metacritic that what I
what I realized is if they may be
looking at it the corporate and say look
all these millions we're gonna pour into
this marketing and we could literally
have the community of social media do
this and have the same effect if not
better than wasting all this money doing
this also I think the get the rules have
changed a little bit now characters only
they're still doing things their way you
know what I'm saying for the most part
you know what I'm saying especially with
Spider-Man but like I just think I think
slowly the industry is changing in that
it's almost like you know what reminds
me of King it reminds me of e3 how
people were like yo do we really need to
be there right and spend all this money
for the booth all this money thing or we
could do our little direct version show
that self-contained that we control the
message
it's cutting money yes from from
trimming the fat right you don't want to
access spend uh it's not traditional no
more we're no longer in a traditional
state know everything has changed
literally since covert so the the ways
that you market now is completely
different I've seen marketing for
Starfield so I'm not going to say like I
didn't see marketing for Starfield I see
it when I go past bus stops I see like
the Billboards for it so um I'm not
gonna say I don't see that I saw the
commercials I mean um I have regular
YouTube so I guess I get a chance to see
the the commercials but I thought it was
dope the commercial and um I talked to
Colt about it and I was and he was
joking he said you know that better not
be the animation I'm like nah I don't
think so but it was it was just a nice
little little type of story whatever I
don't know something whatever's minor
that they can do to try to go viral yeah
opposed to oh we gotta buy out all of
them downtown put up bull boards that's
a lot of money that doesn't make any
sense anymore people don't even interact
that way not getting like I said again
not saying and I don't want it you know
I'm just saying I gotta look at
practicality and if they got the metrics
to say yo we spent all this money on
buses for Hogwarts and all this stuff
and this really didn't equate to what we
thought you know for certain games it
may not gonna be effective right was You
Gonna Take It Well by plenty of people
in the marketing saying that influencer
streaming and podcast marketing is ex
way more effective than shotgun
marketing you know put the only thing I
would push back a little bit yeah go
ahead is I like the way PlayStation
markets like on the Subways and stuff oh
that's why I love that oh I love that
how many people
I I'm not in New York but I'm assuming
Millions
when they had Horizon and um God of War
in Grand Central Station sick yeah I was
sick because Grand Central really really
is like a hub right so everybody's going
different directions want to hit Grand
Central everywhere you go every little
tunnel hallway had it was Sony down like
it was it was crazy it was really good
yeah I mean now the question is again I
don't know the numbers I'm not trying to
be slanderous but like if we look at
Horizon you know here we go did it do
the 10 million right did it do you know
this is what Jim Ryan I'm just talking
about he wants these things to be better
so let's just say I'm just throwing up a
number please PlayStation do not come at
me I don't know what the [__] I'm saying
is it complicated but let's just say
Horizon end up doing alone you know
three four to five is that enough for
them to justify a million or whatever it
is on the marketing budget that you
spent to put all these trainings whereas
Baldur's Gate spent nothing let's just
say you know
than even maybe a Super Bowl commercial
like purple like game like that no okay
me personally it's a lot of money bro no
I'm like stop that like I would rather
go a lot of money too well yeah but I
would rather go get random streamers and
let them play the game and save a
boatload of cash uh it's it's we Market
different yeah and and okay so let's say
talk about the digital kids right we're
talking to the digital kids because
we're not really talking to the adults
the adults we we pretty much know what
we're gonna buy the digital kids that
you're trying to catch their eye they're
not
on a train station looking at Spider-Man
on a train actually I got a perfect
example for you King
you're muted
he muted he muted his Zoom
can humidity Zoom there you go okay I
got a perfect example for you king among
us
no marketing one of the most iconic
games that was out at that time yep yeah
no it it it's proven and it was all
because a couple big streamers on
Twitter yeah and then remember even
seeing these sort of resurgence when
streamers were playing it Summit one
yeah straight single-handedly
probably put the that money and like
look I'm not gonna sit there and say
that traditional marketing doesn't have
a place but when it comes to the gaming
industry that is a very unique style
type of Industry that it's hard to
promote that on a billboard right the
only thing I would push back on
Microsoft is I'm with all y'all but I
don't feel they do enough to promote
like Game Pass though like I feel like
people like we know it but it's like the
services Gamepad I feel like they should
do a little bit better there you know
I'm saying but that's just me you know I
just feel like I mean you got game pass
at Kentucky Fried Chicken game passes
Taco Bell oh I didn't know that game
pass at
um Oreos cookies and you know Nabisco
and all of these places they they trying
to hit the market in certain places what
I would say is they have to do
Partnerships right yeah if they do
partners and they did the Partnerships
with LG and they did the Partnerships
with Samsung uh I think those
Partnerships need to be highlighted more
right okay uh put it on the box of the
television okay in this television you
have the Game Pass App that's on you
know put the stick on it's not too much
uh you have to spend a ton of money it's
just the way that you have these
Partnerships you have to leverage your
partnership in order to get the maximum
I agree so I want to read this comment
from uh
uh from 10 Clan I'm not gonna a q-tang
clan is it is that yeah
my 12 year old didn't know what star
food was until he got the controller and
headset when he found out it was made by
the people who made Skyrim he was height
that's the only reason I feel like they
could do more traditional marketing
because this this isn't No Ordinary
developer this is probably one of the
most prominent developers that's ever
been around they have probably the most
Game of the Year contenders if not game
of the years you can Market this
traditionally I understand why they
don't but I do understand you know
people like kids food that wants to see
more traditional marketing from
Microsoft it's just I don't think that
they understand you know how much that
marketing has died out throughout the
years yeah no I agree I think it's a
change into God the the thing that I
will say though that I still want them
to not stop doing is like when Halo
infinite came out we had that Halo
infinite console remember how quickly we
was like boom so Starfield to me was
like yo that was that was one because
don't everyone the headset you got attic
fire the controller fired like it just
needed that you know Trifecta especially
little man little man would have been
fired with the ass you know what I'm
saying though
face they got space Oh I would have been
very disappointed if there was only a
series s especially but whatever
whatever cause I don't care what it is
if it acts as whoever I just what do you
think if they if they hit you with the
we could only do one I feel like that's
not acceptable don't do it at all if
you're just gonna do one because there's
got all these people that haven't asked
all these people that haven't asked
these people that want each and if
they're like we can only give an S I'mma
be pissed but they kind of did but you
got the people that don't have an X got
the majority of the people they're
having us are going to be mad but they
kind of did it with infinite remember I
don't remember seeing us too serious I
say have no um
yeah I think that's one of those things
that maybe you just have to make people
mad like it's like it is what it is you
know you have the S upgrade to the X if
you want this wow yeah
but and last thing is yeah it looks like
um area uh I could say stalker uh shout
out to boxer but he said Hellboy 2 will
be in the theater so hopefully hopefully
maybe they show some comment or
something something new with that be
dope towerborne um new Microsoft like
similar stuff
um Elder Scrolls online and then armor
core like we said party animals remember
the fun low yeah yeah little that
cyberpunk
it's gonna end bad as soon as he said
they're gonna have um hellblade too
there it's gonna end bad if they show
the same clip
yeah Hellboy 2 is going to be there yeah
it's gonna end back oh my God that
question
we got um we got quakecon coming up this
week yeah
yeah something well shout out to VGC
there's a leadership
video games Chronicles leak about what
maybe uh announced that quakecon so
maybe we get some more details on that
uh whatever it is
uh according to our friends over at
video games Chronicle there is a quake 2
remastered covering that story
but it was it had been rated in Korea
earlier in the year so uh the assumption
is that at quakecon they will be talking
about the next you know iteration of
quake and maybe maybe we've heard uh
Rumblings of maybe uh bringing it back
bringing it back in full force so maybe
maybe there's a little bit of talk about
that but yeah I love quotes
the streets were talking about that uh
yeah yeah see what's gonna go with that
I don't know but uh
payday 3 and the last thing is I do want
to see uh Persona 5 tactica because I
think it's turn based uh Persona just
you know I want to see a little take on
it but now look I like it they gotta
have a big presence there PC game pass
the whole bit it's good to see them in
your where traditionally they all week
so that's all I got anything else when
we move on super chance so yeah let's
get these superchastic a couple uh let
me see
he said they can't do traditional
walking because they put all their money
on influence influencers ass [__] veto
you know I'm gonna funded
right here you know
we got years of lurking we're two
dollars
but finally finally getting into the
chat but I appreciate you for lurking
they probably don't have the console
stock hashtag Starfield yeah
it could be could be
then we got slow-mo backslap remember
for 37 months Lord bronze I opened a
random Barn in a in an abandoned Village
in bg3 and ran into Bungie and the
destiny community in a compromising
situation that's funny that's actually
funny too bad I run into the destiny of
the division Community
convention
it don't exist
it might be like five people it's slower
[Laughter]
gotta kick me with them down
and we have Corey Tidwell five dollar
Super Chat Starfield will have over 1
million concurrent users on Steam in the
first week nobody should be worried
about marketing this is Fanboy nonsense
what it is is let's be real
King know how it is too it's like wait
you know I do see them over yeah they
got this and they got that yeah like you
feel like do you just feel it away find
something why can't we had it it's just
the game is different yo that's awesome
they have fun how would they fun
you're drinking Kool-Aid I hate corn
okay
that is it we're caught up yeah let's go
attic this you've been oh no oh I'm
sorry I apologize just one just jumped
in
on the bright side ten dollars if you
check if Starfield is Game of the Year
quality Word of Mouth advertising for
millions of Game Pass subscribers might
be the best marketing and the fall
Sports Seasons begin next week starting
with the Premier League okay right now
I'm with you on the bright side I agree
I think word about I think they figured
it out these ball these marketing teams
are figured out let these guys do do the
talking and the Metacritic of the score
and it's going it's going to take off
all right so we got addict you up next
with the Starfield helmet on his head
so yeah bought this gate three you've
been playing it right what's going on
and it's a little controversy going on
little man but let's talk about the game
though what's up with this game
uh I love it uh it's it's been one of
the funnest times I've had in the game
oh wow a long time
you know me and that singer and red hood
has been playing it like almost nightly
at this point and what's funny is like
it's just it's a good time man it's a
really fun time
I it's the definition of an RPG you know
we're sitting there and you know light
spoiler but there's a part where you
have to get like a a
you have to get a prisoner out of a camp
you know the capture it's a goblin so
you get her
falling behind you because you pick the
lock and take her out you're not talking
to nobody in the town by the way you're
just taking this prisoner out of the pre
out of the cage and just strolling
through through this town and all the
every time you come across a guard guard
stops you why is this why is this
prisoner out of the cage you have to
roll nothing but you you have to pass
every check still checks okay yeah so
it's like roll a dice you have to get
above a 15 on a 20 dive which is is a
very complicated role you have to do
that four times to get the prisoner out
of the Town
um because every time you go out there
and they're like why is why is she out
of the cage she gonna help us okay gotta
roll the dice if you get the dice right
he says okay I believe you so you got I
got it back go up just a little bit more
gotta do it again
I know nothing about Boulder's game like
I've never played it don't know what's
going on is it like a is it pure that is
it like skill check where you got to
build certain skills up and then if you
wanna have that skills up that increases
the probability so it decreases your
profitability of success based on the
skills that you have and the way you
spec like is it like disco Elysium like
disco leads about playing and then you
gotta put certain things in certain
character or speech and issue that is it
that it's kind of like that so let's say
I have a cleric uh that's one of the
clay one of the standard characters as a
cleric and you're talking to the cleric
and the clerics like
only dialogue that would be from eclair
would be in the conversation so if you
don't have a clerk you wouldn't see it
okay so if you click that let's uh that
is a unique dialogue that only for the
Claire so let's say my careers was at a
certain point where you know I roll a 20
side Dice and it takes a 10. to pass the
check
but because I have those abilities that
I sh that going into this I get like a
plus three all the bonuses on top of it
because you're you're spec okay okay I
think
in the fighting's turn base and I know a
lot of people don't like turn base but
yeah
it's amazing
I would say just one game that's one
game I don't like
I would say the turn base is pretty
pretty color man like we sit there and
well we were fighting this boss that was
like level five and this is an RPG a
true RPG you don't fight level fives at
a level three so we're fighting this
boss and me and red hood we're like dude
we're getting killed every time there
ain't nothing we could do red hood
genius I do because uh you can do like
movement abilities or everyone's got
movement abilities where you could run
Dash and shove you could shove people
and we're so pretty much we're fighting
in the middle is a giant hole
yo try to shove her into the hole
I'm like okay so I jump over there
because I'm a Barbarian so I have more
strength so the shove abilities is way
more high percentage Yeah it's like a 87
percent
yes and I walked in there we we expected
this is this is a video game they're
gonna say you can't do that it's a boss
that doesn't make sense you need to
fight this boss nah the uh you know
Boulder's gay three is like yeah you can
shove that chick straight down that hole
so again isn't she just falling dead
and other classes wouldn't be wouldn't
be able to even do all of that based on
who who you had that kind of thing
everyone could do that but because I was
able to jump to the certain point
because I first we did was we we hid got
to a vantage point where we did where we
saw we could jump behind her and because
I had such high strength I was able to
push her now if another character would
have done that they probably wouldn't
have got the skill checks that was
required to push her and what's funny is
if you fight her she turns herself into
five or six different things it's a very
complicated fight right who's like push
that [__] and you avoided all that
that's dope I like avoided all of that
that's dope
that's the beauty of Baldur's Gate
though that is that that right there
that moment right there is the moment
type of moment that makes people like oh
I can do that in this game and you can
do anything really it's kind of
this is feeling how it's turn based but
it's like disco like it's entire
complete okay yeah you could have up to
four people four people at a party skill
checks okay the the funny thing like a
sandwich there was another scenario
where you have a diplomatic kind of
thing it's like okay you know we don't
want them here they don't want us here
so you're trying to like settle this
you're trying to be the middle God
well I was talking to Red Hot I don't
know why he let me do this okay I don't
know why you let me do this but I was
like I'm gonna kill the leader
so that's how I thought we're gonna
settle this by just killing the leader
of one of the groups
yo tell me how we leave everyone's gone
so we thought okay they ran because we
killed their leader we go to the other
group
we killed their leader and her people
started killing the other group so we're
going up there and there's blood
everywhere she's killed her her group
has killed kids has killed oh women it
didn't matter and we get to the end
there's like a whole Army right here
it's like yeah we reloading we ain't
fighting all these people
so if you get a little Wasteland three
energy too with like you're getting a
little better than white slime oh wait
oh
oh so far
talking crazy yeah and I know ACG would
probably choke me for that all right all
right
that's you I see you from you because I
know how much you like Wasteland how
much I like that's that's big and then
like Boston counter's gonna ask real
quickly Boston or something like that
yeah it's like I said a Boston couch is
just like how you would expect you know
they give you precautions to fight the
beauty about this game about a lot of
their games is you have entire
options of finding them how you want to
fight them sometimes they'll have you
know checks where you can avoid the
fight in general like I said earlier
where I said you were trying to escape
with the guard if I would have felt any
of those checks to get that person out
of that camp all the entire town would
have been all them versus me
um uh so but that's with bosses you know
if if you do bosses correctly and you
pass checks sometimes you don't even
have to fight them but if you don't
you'll end up fighting things that's
like three or four levels higher then
you gotta push them off
you played this before uh you played the
other ones I played the other ones I
haven't played this one because it
although I'm getting the fomo man are
you trying to stay away cause you know
what it do okay what it does and I know
my time commitment so I'm like I it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
yeah so you know that it runs on a rock
right so
he threw the wrong yeah right quick
right quick so it's just like okay yeah
man I I don't I don't know if I'm gonna
jump in but I I'm super excited that
again the older games obviously weren't
larion uh and Larry and jumping in
showing what they could do with the
limited games yeah I believe so yes
so
um yeah man like it's really it's out
there I was talking about earlier like
it's gonna be in the Game of the Year
conversation I don't think because of
the type of game it is it's gonna have
that widespread appeal it'll make it
kind of thing yeah that'll make it like
Achilles winner right it'll be it'll be
nominated I know it's going to win it
it'll probably dominate like the
category most likely right about
strategy or whatever it's running it's
winning rewards it's definitely okay
yeah okay so
um yeah I don't know I made the full
moment get me and I may just get jump in
to really see what it's about but yeah
they did it man they did it and a lot of
the you know the conversation that was
happening earlier when they were like oh
don't ex just because Baldur's Gate is
doing this don't expect our games to to
be that deep or whatever the case may be
that is what a Baldur's game gate game
is right when you think about the world
the DND the the
thousands of different permutations of
situations they man at Baldur's Gate
managed to figure that out in a game
form and give you that level of sort of
choice and consequence in a game in a
way that kind of know RPG has done
had done to that point and has done to
this librarian Studios yeah in terms of
RPGs
they might be the Golden Goose a bunch
because I I don't know I don't know if
they made anything before Divinity but I
ain't played a bad game by then like not
even remotely a bad game all night like
to me nine plus games all of them and
you know this game it's like I said
someone just put in the 800 concurrent
players on Steam at the moment and this
is a turn-based game My People last
question
um is it does it have BioWare energy
with relationships because I know
clearly you could do something with a
bear
okay you do regular oh okay yes yes yes
there's there's romance in this no I was
talking uh I was we were I was waiting I
was like what are you doing right Hood
like why is it because when stuff like
that's going on and you're playing a
co-op it forces you to stay asleep while
they doing they think oh so it is so
yeah so I'm sitting there and I'm like
what are you doing and he's like man I
ain't gonna lie homegirl she she woke me
up man I like you know and I'm like oh I
was like he's like you take up on her
offer I mean of course I did
all right all right little ducks okay
very way you act with this Baldur's Gate
three Mary we are you interested what
you doing well I mean I was interested
when stadia had it right
I was gonna pick up a stadium uh before
that I was gonna get the controller you
know just to play the game and um you
know thank God they they are gone now
then and you know hey bye y'all they're
gone yeah I'm I'm the dude that told
y'all they wasn't gonna make it yeah
yeah feel luminous feel luminous
Harrison I'm the same guy that said
ain't gonna be a PlayStation 6 too can
you remember all right I'm push back on
that one we fighting
like addict said he's a plus 85 on that
so push him
there will be a PlayStation 6 sir
someone in the chat said that Divinity
was a raided a 60s game I'm looking
right now on the the PC rated it's a 93
with 72 Metacritic I'm looking at the
PS4 it's a 92 a 46 Metacritic I don't
know what website you're looking at but
I don't think that look at that trust me
bro website
trust me
[Laughter]
okay so um nah so I'm talking with big
fat Eli in the background and um he's
trying he's trying his best like yo um
I'm getting he's he's knee-deeping it
yeah he's looking okay
you're kidding he's like yo so King
you're gonna get it and he's like yo you
know I'll send it to you I was like no
I said don't do that I said um Starfield
comes out I said then you know I'm still
playing these games and I said I'm still
playing Diablo and I'm still pissed off
with what Diablo did but regardless to
what I'm still in the mix with these
games and I still have a backlog and
there's still stuff coming out for Game
Pass I said so I don't see a moment
where I would throw away hours and hours
and tons of hours of my life that I
don't have to dedicate to that game when
I'm going to dedicate take that time to
Starfield now I do say this I'm
intrigued but I'm I I've evolved to the
point that I don't need to buy a game at
seventy dollars uh just to say I have it
just to be part of the group of all the
Zeitgeist yeah you I got it I ain't miss
out but you're not playing it you don't
play that yeah when you do get a chance
to play it that game is 35 like and you
could have waited so
if if you see a slate and I'm talking to
the adults here I know kids have poor
impulse control I I'm talking to the
adults here that should have a better
grasp on their financial situation and
your marbles right so take your marbles
and say can I play this now no it came
out Tuesday who cares I see it when I'm
able to play it I did that with a mortal
Phoenix Rising
huh
what'd you say it has to have anything
to do with it this is the part I'm
talking about here
this guy here
you see the guy this is the guy the guy
it's the guy the guy just you the guy
yeah I don't know what you know what
king you got you've got thank you I
appreciate that continue yeah so I'm
just saying like yo
I want to play the game but I'm gonna
play the game when I have time to play
the game
an addict saying that you know he's
having so much fun with it it does
produce fomo in me but at the same time
realistically I just don't have the time
for that that's real so I'm gonna get
around to it over that Fortnight time
yeah
you got to give up that Fortnight that's
what it is the sad part is
I stay reaching out the attic and then
he goes he does this
weekly yo where do you get that emote
from all that skin is there I'm like
yeah it was there I was calling you to
come to the game and play oh why didn't
you tell me I'm like I'm here I told you
it was Captain
every week I asked yo the Naruto skins
in there you say no I'm okay I'm good
wow that's what it is you go see her act
like look I might like oh that's a cool
but I never asked
you where you get it
I'm gonna
[Laughter]
say that um this waiting you know maybe
the game passes conditioned you not to
buy games is this the problem is that a
problem going on with you King then you
know you don't want to watch you don't
want to buy games anymore
gives me the luxury to say I can't wait
like some people feel this is a concern
that the Xbox gamer does not buy games
so then y'all buy it and send it to me
like and I'm gonna tell you when I get a
chance to play it when it's five dollars
it's like the store and I'll be like yo
I finally got a chance to play the game
you spent 75 dollars for and I told you
not to do it no it's it's I don't have
the time and you want to sit there and
say oh yeah you know you're playing
fortnite so what that's my fun that's
like my life that's my thing like I
don't sit there and say oh you're
playing that game you're missing out on
fortnite I don't care I feel that I'm
feeling it you know I got the message
because that's what they said if you
like these those Game Pass guys gotta
watch him the death of the industry you
don't buy you're not creating the
engagement wait a second timeout the
death of the industry yes this you don't
hear the streets talking I don't listen
to them this maximum it's a really
expensive has made this for me oh so
you're speaking from a consumer
perspective I'm speaking from yo this is
dope
you're saying you could care less if
Microsoft runs their business into the
ground that's what they're trying to say
oh here we go to the ground oh I'm just
saying if you're speaking as a consumer
I'm not throwing up check it out
consumers I I don't that's their problem
right right it is it's their problem I
don't care so there you go wait a second
time I did I get a bag from them there
you go
all right I should not kiss this is
about the lack of a bag
I'm not on payroll and I'm not an
employee but I will say this though yeah
we welcome
let's say they got uh you know 35
million people that pay 15 a month right
these people is finance and Microsoft
these are the same people that might
only buy one game a year but you rope
these idiots into paying 15 a month in
perpetuity because they're afraid to get
out of game pass because they don't know
what's gonna come up in there next so
you even tell me they're gonna run a
game they stuff in the business
um into the ground their business into
the ground no what they actually did was
how can we keep a fool in suspense they
got you like you you pay your money and
you're like man if I get out of game
pass this month and they release
Boulder's Gate and they do it that's
when you say and they always do it every
time you buy a game you go out you go
get a game and then they show up in Game
Pass you'll be like this damn yeah
you know what this what this I'm going
to chill out I'm gonna play what I got
and I'm gonna buy what I need that's it
and if you don't need it don't buy it
and that's me I don't need it I don't
buy it no stop it you're just speaking
so practically from a consumer
perspective I thought you would be
worried about the industry because you
know I don't care
my Turbo Graphics die I saw my Neo Geo
go the way the dinosaur sake is gone
like I can't I'm actively hunting you
guys like stadium is gone we got one in
the bag I'm looking at you baby
failed though so let's get to let's get
to the to the smoke
so clearly there's been some issues here
with this game as far as the release
date and uh laryn coming out obviously
you know it's developed on PC first I'd
explain it now and then peace uh
PlayStation that comes out um actually I
think around star film September same
day like September 6th or whatever it is
so we got that and then the uh Xbox uh
version's not not coming anytime soon
because Larry looks like you'll need
more development time looks like there's
an issue with split screen developer
came out it stated that that caused a
lot of controversy Series S another
developer I think football was it uh
what's remedy came out so yeah you know
they they may have had an issue with
difficulty with the series that's so
little man is is coming up and King and
they're talking about like you know
maybe it's holding the generation back
and you know that this this is a big
problem in that you know Microsoft needs
to do something about it or or it was a
mistake I'm just telling you what the
streets is obviously okay okay what the
streets are saying first Xbox has a
thing called Cloud bro and it actually
really works
you can stream that game you can stream
it well you can't you can't stream until
it come out because they're now they're
not because according to the devs right
Microsoft wants parody feature parody uh
Larry and Larry Studios that makes both
the game okay so the issue they said
they're having it it's a um potential
issue with split screen because they
have drop-in Dropout Co-op like attic
was saying and then it's a split screen
mode right and I guess because of the
memory of the series s they're saying
that they're having a little bit more
difficulty getting that out so as of
right now they need more time before
they can put it out at the same time
because people thought is it the same
dudes that had this game for the last 20
years
he's the same dudes that was on Stadium
they couldn't get it together these are
the same individuals that can just
launch on PC and can't launch on
everybody at the same time these are the
same dudes that we asking to get it
together listen man I don't want your
excuses we got a little black man out
there a little black man can handle
everything don't come for us man little
white man is a little short in certain
aspects but little black man is out here
moving it's still the same CPU it's
still the same like little black man
still got the same issues
yeah so so the question remains again PC
they came up with the folks on PC now
then they're doing PlayStation but the
series you know what I would do what
buy them and make them shut up attic
said that it didn't go well
yeah
I'm with your attic I'm with you bye
Sony did that with with house Marquette
remember that it was they were sitting
there saying
they said it's not our game it's your
Hardware they got purchased the
following week and got a secret
and we heard nothing since yo it was
literally crashing burning short now
PlayStations and they was like nah it
ain't our game this Hardware week and it
was like oh who said that they did buy
them now and shut them up so listen you
said little man did what does it mean
that don't hit him on Twitter he said
you know they just having a little cool
man can't handle what they just shut
them up oh so you want them a quiet okay
that's it just buy them now now now you
on a quiet list you you wanna keep
talking yeah oh so you go to silence
them that's how we do it in business
[Laughter]
we have to wait for the Xbox version of
this game a little longer more
development time is needed how we
feeling people are going hard on the
series s
look I think if you want to make a
statement that the series ask
potentially hold the series X back I
would say that's more of an argument but
if you want to say the series that's
just holding the industry back no it's
called the lowest denominators of the PC
markets
you know if it's just Series S and
series X you can make a huge argument
saying that you know the boundaries of
the series s makes it to where they
can't make better games for the series X
and that that's fair but at the end of
the day there's no series that's or
series that's exclusive everything's on
PC so that's not an argument either it's
like well it comes down to this it's
we I don't think that this is a matter
of could they get this game working or
not I think it's just what's going on
right now you know maybe six months ago
and this is all speculation I'm not
going out and saying this is speculation
but it's like you know you look at it
let's say six months ago they were
talking about you know do we need to
delay the game and they're looking at
the series that's okay this is going to
take a couple more weeks a couple more
months of development time to make sure
the S comes out and runs good because
the game runs good you know they're not
they're not Studios that just release
games buggy and stuff they actually have
quality products that actually work the
way they're supposed to for the most
part they're like you know what we we
don't want to delay the game and they're
like well September well what's coming
out on the PlayStation really nothing at
that time
on Xbox oh star filled so we can
actually it's it makes more business
sense for us to put more energy into the
PS5 version into the into the PC version
because that Xbox series s and X both of
them together they're not going to be
done on time and at least if we release
this uh the the series versions later we
won't get cannibalized by Starfield in
September you think so I think that's
what's used on it I mean
Goblin attic answer that's this question
I just I think that's just the Realms of
like I'm not saying that that is the
sole reason but I will say that I think
in the logistic things of marketing and
the logistic things of their financial
backing it makes more sense to delay the
series acid X and not delay the whole
game right all right because it's it's
very easy hat addict yeah I'm gonna get
you a conspiracy hat conspiracy hat
attic is the game done
and they just holding it back because it
don't won't sell right going up again
wait are you implying or are you
implying that because of the Xbox's
exact release date of Starfield it will
who's the all of a sudden are you
applying this boy did they just attack
I'm just asking conspiracy addict and
then they point to little man in the
corner like he
I mean why but why would you let them do
that why would you let little man take
that out yeah and ruin your relationship
with the part with the business partner
by exposing him they look like the
Savior later when we got
I think this is a matter of time and
effect
um you know what's let's say they could
even get a running in September why
they're going to compete with star Phil
and one of them alone off the water they
say first of all it's not even about
what game is better it's literally one
you pay and what is in game and it is
but like they'll get their boot smoked
like no disrespect yeah and it's like
again this is the first time ball
there's a Baldur's gig coming out like
you know that was you know built from
the ground up to be on consoles as well
as PC right so it's not although it's
not day and date they built them kind of
simultaneously this is not it's still
new to a lot of console players and the
people that would really super be
interested in it although I was seeing
in a Super Chat that somebody said like
it's it's the most pre-ordered game on
PlayStation numbers
yeah right so it's like it's like we're
gonna support this like it's one of our
own and they're gonna be out here
camping we got an exclusive
they don't even play those type of games
no it's gonna be funny though
the PlayStation Fanboys when we're
playing Stark though they're gonna be
posting videos of Voters gate three it's
like dude you're playing old news we
played this last month I think it's
smart I think it's smartphone
I've saved from a business standpoint
that's smart but I'ma roast you if you
do that
that's a game they came out that they
would have played and you're going to
find out they pre-order but they don't
they don't follow through they got they
got a good talk game but they don't
they so every day
that's what they're gonna do they like
they're gonna post their character they
took 30 minutes to make and they didn't
put even more than they put into the
character development into the actual
game itself they're gonna get past like
halfway to the tutorial oh this is turn
base I didn't know that like worse than
that attic they gonna pre-order right
now take a screenshot of the pre-order
and then two days before the game come
out cancel said pre-order
they get their money back I hope the
game sells well I do because it's like
you know I do think turn base is is
starting to make a real big comeback I
see more and more turn-based games but
turn based on a triple a scale of this
magnitude is very rare and I want them I
wanted to to be screaming to the other
Publishers there's a fan base for this
you just can't make lackluster versions
of these games and want them to sell now
if they're immersive like they are on
Border Skate 3 because Divinity sold
well too it's like yeah people will come
out and they will support but you've got
to actually make the game
you know the RPG kingpins right now
it's like I said the biggest industry in
the biggest problem in the industry in
my personal opinion is Trend sending
people always go for the fortnite bags
the GTA 5 bags uh you know I can't think
of another one at the top
I would say Apex is more of the fortnite
thing though the the breath of the wild
bags you know they want the the
excitement and the success of these
Brands these games
but very few of them adapt and make it
their own and even less of them they
want that money that they that these
massive brands are generating but they
have a fraction of the game that they
want you know a lot of his Trend chasing
too you know I get what you said so soft
band a little man is in the cross heads
once again
holding back to jail this damn ass man
was a mistake that's what that streets
are saying back to back
the realities of having less Ram that's
not fake right that's for real that's
real the thing about it is if if what's
claimed is that it's local
Co-op yeah and I'm just like dude
I'm sorry Halo infinite hello it's the
local co-op yeah that's right
I'm not saying it shouldn't be there
right now but either didn't have it
either right apparently the co-op thing
is hard to do like there's been a bunch
of devs that's dropping tired it's funny
it's funny Alexander because I can't
think of any next-gen game that's doing
split screen anymore anymore that's like
an old feature for Bank yeah that's like
for back in the day like and what's
funny is as much as I like the option
there and I just want them to give us
options you know me and smooth got into
like a little debate where he's like
just remove split screen no one plays
games at home it's like but who are you
to tell them to not give us more options
right and then Microsoft is making it a
mandate Larry it is right about this
Microsoft's bigger than men that you
cannot drop something on the X and then
the S don't have that feature at all
that's right so they're not trying to
hear that let's get the dojo
again that's a self-imposed rake oh you
you play with Microsoft I'm just saying
like if you when you really think about
it when you really think about it how
many people are going to use this and to
the point where you're not having the
game when you're not having the game
when it's out because I'm gonna tell you
right now
Microsoft's so close with the PC market
I could have seen an Xbox XS version out
day in day with the PC leaving the
PlayStation behind
to come out a month later right I could
I could have seen that so you could have
had marketing you could add everything
sort of in line day and day with the PC
version and been right there for that
Zeitgeist moment if that is what's
holding it back for real
um and to me because again this is
Microsoft very PC Centric this would
have been a big deal for them to be
there day and day for that okay so
that's my thing if it's just that
this game comes out
beginning of next year for Xbox but it
comes to Game Pass do you think that
makes up for the delay in the game for
me I mean I mean they come in the game
faster makeup right because for King it
hasn't come out to listen gameplay
exactly but again he's going to be
zeitgeisting it up by himself
but I will say this it will get a second
win it will get that second win in Game
Pass right we're like oh my God all
these people that didn't play it are
going to play it down Game Pass so that
will be there and maybe for a game like
Baldur's Gate where you don't expect the
engagement on a console side to be there
from day one just because of the type of
game it is
um maybe maybe maybe that works I'm just
saying that they had a big opportunity
to be there day and date with this huge
release pause
that's very PC Centric
at a moment where they're really trying
to grow their PC base as well right with
Game Pass so to me it's just like if
that is the thing that's holding it back
and nothing else I think it's an
unnecessary it's an unforced error that
you could adjust because the King's
Point the game the game could be ready
the game could be ready apart from that
b there is a strong contingitive Series
S owners they're just not gonna have a
feature that's gonna be set a new
precedent that you just get the scraps
and you deal with you yeah
it'll be mad for a minute they'll be mad
for a minute and then they'll get over
it and I can be real I'm agree with Saul
ditch that ditch that feature wow
I'm about people getting the option the
option that's preventing them from
coming out on the entire platform simple
Xbox needs to make that decision do we
want to lose out on games and it looks
like they said they just need more time
I'm saying like a day and day kind of
thing
gonna add it later okay that's another
alternative my thing is this right I
think it's a feature that's really
grandfathered and when you think about
it okay they say this is a PC first game
PC Centric game which clearly it is who
is who is landing it up who's bringing
their monitor and PC to their boy's
house
I feel you on the usage rate I'm not
gonna never fight you on that I'm just
saying the president y'all sentence
guys it's just dangerous for a hot
minute then it's over nobody cares okay
so let's say that they don't cancel the
feature they're like look we're gonna
release
the split screen on the Xbox series X
but not on the S and then we're going to
in the background slowly be building
that feature into the series s you won't
get it at launch but you get it later on
the on the ground so we've been
launching on finish games oh well here's
here I mean we just complained that Red
Foley has 60 at large but then everybody
was up
Uprising too where people are like Hey
Y'all kind of quiet over there Arcane
what happened to these features they
will come yeah
they said something he he quote tweeted
he's like better question where's that
60 frames yeah I'm saying I remembered
it was but it was torches and tiki
torches picket lines because of 60
frames and that'll be okay I feel like
when it comes to like a split screen
feature over like a 60 frame feature
it's like split screens down here at 60
frames up so seriously
it's just box Chicken Little bed is
second he's a second class citizen now
no he isn't he's always been a sacrifice
system to me that's what you're doing I
mean he's always been one of me I don't
own one so I don't care oh you don't
care I got them in the house well you
know I'm talking about a series his
ex-consumer that is not getting a game
because of another console that is part
of it not encoding my console I'm
talking about a series excuse that I
bought this Michael says Microsoft said
this is the way I could get in to the
ecosystem I didn't want to pay 500 I got
a PlayStation I got a switch they told
me that he go did they promised me that
he gonna do everything that the big man
doing and now y'all telling me I get
burgers no fries I get this no [__]
how many people coming over your house
hanging out what how many but there's
more of us
and we we helped you you know we helped
you with Japan okay we helped you with
Japan for a couple of bucks I got no
problem pissing all of you off to get
what I want you again but we represent
more to y'all guys we release the game
to little man let little man get like
two people on little man playing a
little bit we got to see the splits I
think it might be more a little bit when
you go to click local oh there's
definitely more
but I don't
oh we lost them we lost them for a
second
all right there you go okay a little bit
out here working then you cut off I said
little
me doing his thing and you know I don't
I don't have to do um local co-op I
don't do it wow let me jump it y'all get
on my nerves um
I can't believe y'all right now this
disrespect a little bit listen man look
at the end of the day I get it on the
feature the usage rate y'all know I
can't win that argument they probably
put up the stats and we see who's
actually utilizing those features it's
probably super super small I give you
that the only thing I'm talking about
from the larian standpoint is that one
this is we got it I would be nice
not all developers are created equal
right that's that's one right and also
even if they are created equal is
resources right so clearly this is a PC
Centric game that you you know why you
know because you can't send it best kid
it's not even launching at the same time
as the PS5
that's right it's pla they put all their
resources towards the PC and then they
go on PC for PS5 they know they're gonna
get the most money on the PC regardless
of however they split it or whatever the
internals is they are clearly not doing
a simultaneous launch because let's just
say series XS is the problem then
technically you should be able to launch
PlayStation 5 and PC at the same time so
they have made a concerted decision to
do PC first then they're going to do PS5
now with me on the series X Series S
thing
first of all I do feel you have to have
parody you have to you can Microsoft
marketed that system to be the entry
point to get people into this ecosystem
period you know you are saying no you're
saying no you're saying you're not
getting that when did they when did they
promise feature parody on every single
Marion themselves the developer said it
he said the reasons I don't know Larry
asked they said why can't it come out
without that and they was like Microsoft
has mandated that we have to have
parents and that game ain't coming out
could start feeling these streets I'm
just telling you I mean tell the truth
in the devil I'm sick and tired of
hearing this right now they got mad
excuses now they won't blame little man
little man out here rocking and bopping
don't play with the memory he ain't not
with the memory listen you gotta prove
it to me I don't believe you I'm gonna
go away
all I will say oh I was saying little
man I I think it could happen and they
think it could happen they just said
they need more time well I'm with you
funny how it's more time after starfish
all right now where I'm with you is how
they chose to divvy up when they gonna
do it and who they gonna give resources
to I'll give you that I'll give you that
that
PlayStation so happen right have a good
game and Playstation so happen to have a
larger install base that you could
happen to make more money and by the way
the Xbox version if you happen to drop
it on that day Joshua stuff I'm with you
on that part the PlayStation so happened
to move Spider-Man out of September
because they were scared of somebody
that was coming outside too but but they
said Boulder's Gate we can fill you into
this slot we can slide you in here if
you come over here
we will allocate resources towards you I
feel all I'm saying I'm not on the road
is series as trade yet I am with addict
I do think it's just a resource issue I
think
God yes this game come out and they do
sleep seamless Co-op couch co-ops
seamlessly no problem on little man yeah
are you gonna smell BS no no they I know
they could do it it's just like you know
why I know what they can do it's the
same way like cyberpunk came out and it
wasn't no 60 frames per second motor a
little man at first and then it's like
three four to six months or whatever it
was and then it came why can't they do
that because like you said it's
development time they they have whatever
reason I'm not in that that studio they
have chosen to prioritize a PC release
first then stagger a Playstation release
second that's on them I don't know their
reasons then that's that's that's a like
Sovereign
that's what I'm saying that that I'm
leaning right I'm snitching this way
just like little man didn't have a 60
frames second mode and cyberpunk but
that's what I didn't have a couch Co-op
because I said I said it's a Microsoft
rate because you said it was the
Microsoft but I remember seeing larion
seeing something saying something about
we don't want to do that we don't want
to we don't want to do that to our game
correct and it just happened to fall in
line with whatever Microsoft said they
wanted from series X and that's part but
I remember larion saying something that
I felt like nah we don't want to do that
to the game and it's just like okay
obviously they have confidence they can
get it done yeah that's all I'm saying
they said they could do it so if I think
it still benefits Xbox anyway because
like we all said it don't make no sense
dropping on September 6th with Xbox
version anyway and you clearly ain't got
enough resources to do it in time
because you have prioritized your PC bag
and your PlayStation bag first really so
I'm with you all I would say is this
like
the feature pack I just want to be
careful with the feature parody because
it's like you you they whether whether
it was a mistake or not Microsoft came
in saying we're doing two consoles
that's what they said they said this is
the low end and it's the high end get in
where you fit in if we start playing
this game you don't get this and that it
gets sticky it gets messy and I'm just
concerned about that that that's what my
thing but what I will give you this
solve for I feel where you're going what
I will give you this is this is where I
will I will give some blame to Microsoft
here you're gonna be happy
y'all need to say y'all Engineers over
on the biggest yeah on the biggest game
that got the zeitgeist
that you could potentially missing out
on with a simultaneous I will give you
that like you need to get in there you
need to call up the team and say yo how
can we help what's going on where are
you experiencing the issues are that
kind of thing because this is like
according to attic this is the RPG or
the the this is the Zeitgeist
you're gonna be ringing the bells
they're gonna be looking through the
blades of the window
yeah we ain't opening that door because
we already know that game work we just
said
maximum amount of dollars
[Music]
I'm just I'm defending a little man a
little bit today I'm down with that buy
them damn
buy them and set them up
what's up volume and see and put the
disc in and say see it works
let's see if they buy them and don't
tell them and like
probably you you know you're trying to
help uh no man I'm here to actually you
know uh cancel it what do you mean move
things along and you see someone coming
in there like you know hey Phil's Pizza
what platforms you guys on did they
start going over them they get to play
oh about that
oh stop that version that's what we
doing we doing stop that version again
next week
they said we just send the gold copy to
go get pressed over in the cab stop that
cap
yeah
that would be so dope because they would
have nothing for such
yeah out of pocket anyway that's all
right guys this is a fun little sketch I
just wanted to see what y'all thought
about that that was wrong I didn't even
expect that
Trump I was the barber shop I wanted to
get on his nerves I want to see where he
was at with it no listen my little man
hasn't I bought little man right and I
had it for the job right and what
happened was I had the Beastie set up in
my office and my boss just burst
so I'm like I can't he didn't say
anything because it I was on my lunch
break whatever but it was well since I
cannot let this I can't it can't I know
what happened you betrayed little man
for the rock I know what you did I
betrayed a little man for the steam neck
first
I thought you know it was you know what
it is though no actually no I returned a
little man for the for the laptop right
because the laptop is like okay I could
just switch the screen and I'm I'm
typing things yeah whatever I'm working
y'all I'm working the little man you
can't do it even look at them
you know
there's no other
I had that we hired him for
I think I can't get rid of that so
actually little man might be going to my
niece and nephew later this year my
sister permits him
they won't be playing couch Co-op
not at all that's amazing it's gonna be
interested to win that joint do drop
though what it what it does really it's
gonna be very interesting
right now it did one up it is the number
one most pre-ordered it's crazy crazy
let's see how much it sells oh damn
right before they gonna all cancel their
Mass cancel okay I can't I can't do it I
can't do it we just needed to change the
narrative
act like we was outside anyway
yeah more pre-orders the Madden 24. wow
Mortal Kombat wow that's crazy
Spider-Man 2. that's crazy this kind of
book dude that's kind of Bonkers yeah
listen so you know it's caps
are you implying that PlayStation don't
play those type of games yo you know
that's cap for these dudes you know is
is okay all right guys they got together
in the spaces and was like oh my gosh
we all gonna pre-order and the three
days before we gonna cancel all right so
we're gonna we're gonna show the world
the force of the PlayStation team
you are ridiculous wait a minute over a
first party game nah I don't got a
number say what the numbers say yeah
they just pulled up the numbers on Xbox
but a little man stopped it I cannot
wait to see the numbers have canceled
you want to see the final numbers I know
what you think actually on Playstation I
don't think you can cancel like that
PlayStation takes your money and they
run to the distance just don't
pre-install I bet see it's on your hard
drive B
in a tweet I wanted to get the name of
those sunglasses you were wearing at the
beginning of the stream oh you went to
jail for okay I'll hit you with the link
let me put that out there
then we got Stitch five dollar Super
Chat Cog did you say that this Florida
heat pressure cooked your beef oh
yo yo it was wild hot out there
yeah the humidity oh yeah it was crazy
hit the like so we can save the Alaskan
camel yeah hit the like button again
384 likes so we can save the couch Co-op
potatoes
Spider-Man 2 looks like a PS4 game
I can't wait
there we got a fixable G member for 43
months Lord bronze and we give a shout
out to the narrator in Baldur's Gate DND
goodness yeah the narrator is very very
good
then we got Lord Metroid two dollars
which had been playing D D since I was
13. Baldur's Gate 3 is for me salute
[Music]
Corey Tidwell five dollars for chat
bunch of over hyping it's a good game
but Remnant 2 is better also this game
is complete they will be there will
probably be not be any add-ons okay
Smoke a Little Smoke
Jimmy Yandel five dollar Super Chat on
the PlayStation store it's the number
one pre-order game yes yes we just saw
that uh Robert Kelly 2000 who chat if
you don't like dice rolling you
recommend uh no I know all about yeah
I definitely don't recommend if you like
absolutely against dice rolling but I
think
you gotta actually experience the game
to understand like the dice roll and
things aren't like horrible it's a fun
aspect it's like that anticipation right
when you click the the button and it
starts rolling you're like oh God oh God
he said oh God please
yeah we got wpnx 84 two dollar super
chat with the one up uh hippo Emoji
thank you so much
then we got base 23 bkny 20 super chat
but all this gay three has jumped to the
number two best-selling pre-order on PSN
not number one looks like since
Starfield is not on the PlayStation bg3
will get more sales and attention for
being a timed exclusive because of the
series s
okay yeah the funny part about it is you
can't say that y'all don't got nothing
to play over there
so we gonna pre-order this day because
this is the only thing that come out
that month good I'll roll with that
serious ain't got nothing to do with
what's going on with you guys over there
little baby Starfield we playable on the
series s
look at that and who's gonna argue
Starfield is not an infinitely larger
game than Boulder's game
you see okay see how it's gonna go but
nah I feel you on that I feel you on
that what else we got and we got
Homeless Bird five dollar super chat now
that addict is distracted by bg3 I feel
much more secure in my relationship with
my Farmer waifu Dr take me look to the
realm and the Lords
Luke is the doctor off of persona 5.
yeah yeah she's the one of age she's the
one that's actually of age yeah okay
everybody else what's funny is I'm at
the point where I can actually romance
her oh man you're about to get it all
right I can romance like five chicks on
Persona right now
[Music]
we got face 23 became why to our Super
Chat bg3 just hit 800 000 concurrent
players on Steam
um
how many of those games was hacked
[Laughter]
[Music]
the dev literally got the Sony bag and
are gagged and they can't talk about no
he came out said no exclusivity yeah
but it's it's finagling going on you
finagling you ain't exclusive but you
forget
hey you said I'm gonna get this PC bag
over here I'll see y'all in a second
hold on what's up
and your Xbox y'all got that stuff yo
girl I'm coming over to get that bag
over there they finagling they know no
paperwork
best
then we got let me see Robert Kelly five
dollar Super Chat can't wait for people
to hand wave sub 720p games on switch
next year switch two next oh we're gonna
talk about it devs focus on the more
successful platforms don't say you don't
say it does you gotta love the next
topic whatever that platform is it will
be running Call of Duty exactly
exactly there we got just bring it three
dollars stupid chat where's Halo split
screen canceled for parody
there you go it is true though like
nobody don't do split screen It's gotta
be high CPU High memories
they ain't got to check that box I think
the only people I know doing it still is
Borderlands like so Borderlands the late
last one has like low three I think so
someone in the chat tell me yeah let me
know who who's what's last game I think
that I know it is everything could have
split screen I'd never know because
the only people who do is split screen I
know is still Nintendo like Nintendo
remember back in the day Minecraft
wouldn't let you do split screen unless
you just hooked up to an HDMI yeah
yeah unless you hooked up the HDMI word
yeah that's great
let me see yeah here okay Corey took
well five dollars to the chat here's the
non-conspiracy DirectX 12 adoption isn't
where it should be and that is
Microsoft's fault this is their biggest
problem facing them look it behooves
them to uh make sure they're engineers
and their tools uh uh you know get to
the the AAA devs that are really putting
out these popular titles so that they
don't miss out
then we have Nintendo Taco five dollar
Super Chat someone explained how GTX
1060 with eight gigs of RAM PC can do
split screen but somehow the series s
can't of course like I said no no those
are bars those are bars and that's what
I've been trying to tell people with
this whole series that's holding that
that's what attic said attic ladies it's
literally there's some of the more
popular PC skus are lower than this
Series has and they're finding a way so
again it's development time it's
resources and they have chosen yeah yes
we gotta step away too from these direct
comparisons yes because it's not the
same correct GTS 1060 is a GPU that only
does yes Graphics the ram is only for
that when you're doing that good point
when you're talking about a series
that's that's a system on a chip it all
works together in conjunction yeah
theoretical power does not translate the
same it just doesn't it just doesn't we
can make these comparisons but you have
to understand where they come from
absolutely it's it's not the same
it's not the same thing and then also
it's familiarity with the with the
configuration of the series as well like
it's a separate it's a separate thing as
well it's development time resources
honestly storm the building and find out
but I will say lowest lowest common
denominator is still a factor in game
development like for sure that's still
part of it but yeah that's your PC and
it's a piece they're closer to these
systems are closer to PC now they ever
have been yeah then we have the
professor with the five dollar Super
Chat I think it was a mistake to launch
the series s in the first place launch a
digital slash disc series X the S keeps
creating an unnecessary narrative oh
call it pixel bgs they're already proven
in an ally and it's not more than eight
gigabyte total with all the Ally as far
as um the configurations the memory slot
so we'll see it's on Microsoft to show
but I will say In fairness to the series
s we literally have like maybe one or
two examples and this may be one of it
whereas the rest of the games maybe they
have parity or at least at the at the
minimum feature you know feature set
parity whereas as opposed to the yeah
frame stuff like that so yeah okay then
we have
c-dub813 305 5 super chat uh attic
talking about roasting people on PS5
playing bg3 what about ghost wire death
Loop and fist they were being played on
PS5 over a year ago I played those games
so I can't roast them yeah I will Rush
myself I played those games I actually
have a review out for death Mike said
you missed oh sorry somebody said yeah I
missed the Super Chat oh yes yeah Mike
this right that's why I jumped it I see
it right here uh Mike with the ten
dollar Super Chat isn't it funny Laren
came across technical problems with Xbox
at the same time they got a marketing
deal with Sony and PS5 but it was
announced what a coincidence you're the
king back now you ain't King territory
now it's just finagles wait did they get
a marketing deal is it just the fact
that this a is coming out first there is
switch
who got the Walking Dead yo I don't know
[Laughter]
in front
face for the 29 I read that one okay I
sent another one that you missed oh yeah
I read it Baldur's Gate uh three has
jumped to the number two best-selling
pre-order on PSN looks like since
Starfield is not playing uh it's not on
Playstation bg3 will get more sales and
attention for being a Time exclusive
because of the series s yeah we read
that one all right cool
the hand waving
yeah uh Robert Kelly five thousand which
had little man just isn't enough
Microsoft will have to scrap it next
year once the PS5 Pro drops PS5 did it
right 100 difference between disk and
digital SKU not their last oh man be
quiet hey that's scrapping that's not
happening are you gonna scrap it next
year because the paystation 5 is going
to come out it's gonna be 7.99 and that
they doing it right over there man
I want to know how right they did it all
right Faith still sets off that it's not
that one
I missed one before that he said another
time to it yet oh God I mean it's below
that's another 20 Super Chat he hasn't
got to it oh okay so okay okay so nobody
relax
Ed man that's twenty dollars
I'm in the fan funding tab I only see it
in color
we got it I got that uh let me see then
we have Corey Tidwell five dollars which
app the series s was designed around the
idea that sfsfs would be mainstream if
devs utilized it it utilized it little
man has more than enough RAM again
Microsoft fault
little man is not the issue is finagling
going on and if you and if you
can mirrors they already you fell for
the distraction I think I think a lot of
it is is introducing a two
console skill at the beginning of a
generation like that is probably a lot
of like
newness in terms of like workload for
certain devs and stuff and I think the
devs are just frustrated with the extra
work yeah and I think that's what it
mainly is I don't think so I think this
first of all they was bought and paid
for and was going to be on stage so that
game was coming out on stadia and they
did not care about anything else then
when they found out stadia died they
said all right time to get these bags
they already got that bag so they was
like okay that bag we got it we already
spent that money today we already spent
that money
what they got in September over there
for the PlayStation they ain't got
nothing B all right so yeah we're gonna
get that bag over there so what what
about the Xbox well they got Starfield
so you gonna get that game pass back
later so how come we can't put them out
at the same time don't explain that
little
I'm stupid
strikes again
news it's how it goes down behind the
scenes developer reporting
it was like he stole it what
yeah oh yeah we have Iron Mike with the
two dollars Super Chat little man needs
a memory expansion like the Saturn and
the s16 oh god he's a ram car yeah let's
go I will say a little man running split
screen I went ahead nothing after this
talking about almost everybody that's
complaining I want to see your split
screens up I want to see all your
friends over at your house and you're
sitting there with your little hats on
and your little get ups and you're
playing both roll the dice sitting there
sitting there dressed in bed costumes oh
man Savage and a whole furry joke but um
let me go let that go yeah we have no
Adventurer remember for 22 months Lord
silver a Nintendo topic the aliens are
here
this game of the year over Starkville
taking bets now King Cog will be pulling
up King kagu we're pulling up the more
sija on X-Men at Christmas love the show
so talk about blood sausage again here
we go
no it is no conversation surrounding
that title right now that title has came
and went boldness gauges me to talk to
people
so they said they saw almost 20 million
in a week are y'all
no I ain't say they ain't got a shot
they got all the shots in the world so
big how to Todd Howard throw you know
situations on the table I gotta see
starfell before I start saying if
they're gonna yank the the victory right
now
I Gotta See Starfield first right now
you can't release a game uh the
successor and come in at a lower
resolution sorry message
my personal game video right now would
probably be Baldur's Gate but I think
the one winning would be Zelda no glory
pig boldest that's it
continue
then we have face 23 we can't why 120
which have bg3 is not scared of
Starfield bg3 is coming out the same
time on PS5 and Starfield is on Xbox
you're across the street yelling nobody
cares
that don't count because that's on
another platform like you and my cell
block talking trash [__] myself like me
he'll get mopped out son I agree it
doesn't it's not the same
gonna come up Snake Eyes
they're on that they're on the like the
highway scrimmage on the other side
knowing neither one of them could get to
each other exactly
yeah we got Spartan six six one five
dollar Super Chat I hope we can unlock
R.A Salvatore's characters like they
were in the first two Ballers gate games
yeah you had artists out to characters
in there as well you had a icewind Dale
characters
um let me see then we have Gamers play
HUD x0 remember for 32 months Lord
bronze Rumor Has It 2025 is when Xbox
series X will have an upgrade available
as well as a disc a discless one
interesting indeed we'll see we'll see
if the pro happened I think that does
change and yeah Microsoft can pivot we
know these those teams Jason Ronaldo and
them got they they always cooking up
systems
we'll see what happens if uh Playstation
still follows through
all right Lord
don't sleep on Boulder's Gate it's a 25
year old series because the fans have
kept it alive and the boulders fans are
legion that is true oh that's a game
yeah
I mean it's gonna do what it's gonna do
with everybody's leaving on it we just
talking about you know dudes out here
talking about oh it's you know it's
Starfield is afraid of that no they're
not no he was a stadia game bro hold on
you was a whole stadium slow down why I
gotta be that distinction like they
don't count they don't care breaks B you
was on Stadium
I mean regardless what game came out
when I think us as consumers got to be
grateful there's a month apart from
these games yeah I'm happy Loki I was
like I knew what I was playing
regardless I was like if that came out I
guess guess who's not getting played you
see pop your breaks B I know there's a
Todd God house outside I don't care what
about here speeding down the lane pump
your brakes then we have a Abney and
grand five dollar Super Chat as long as
gear is five and it takes two exists the
Baldur's three devs have no excuse
tell the truth and shame the devil
let's see
you know who they are Dragonheart yo we
five dollars we chat hashtag peace love
life to the Lords keep up the good work
my man king you're a good soul my man
been watching old IOP shows and King was
dangerous love Bros
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollars
Super Chat Debs aren't using the memory
saving the memory saving feature there
is no capping it's just facts shaking my
head you know get myself in there to
help them nothing wrong with the little
man version y'all
it's finagles
there we go Eternal should I for ten
dollars Super Chat Lauren is acting like
Errol Spence looking for a lucky punch
but keeps missing until they get clipped
by the Xbox Community they managed with
divinity two with divinity original sin
one and two
I'm not gonna address that because
that's a sore spot for me
[Music]
you hit me in my field sir and I don't
appreciate it that we have Craig Keely
five dollars first super chassis
[Laughter]
foreign
Lords thanks for the laughs and bring on
Starfield
salute salute
now we got Texas member for 10 months
Lord bronze salute Lords bgs and Xbox on
marketing correct word of mouth and
social media ads and social media ads
tagged y'all on X with two I with two I
saw on Instagram just today so he did
some advertisements out there
uh we're caught up nice all right roll
over Tick Tock and everything like get
to it Nintendo man this is me uh new
console reportedly due out second half
of 2024 partner studios are in
possession of depth kids and the system
is said to accept game cartridges this
is courtesy of games industry.biz also I
believe uh Wario 64 has some information
a little bit more information as well
two sources that VGC spoke to suggested
that the council could launch with an
LCD screen instead of the more premium
OLED in order to bring it down the
course Nintendo next gen can be used
portable has cartridge slot for physical
games and backward compatibility support
is unclear and then
and then uh yeah kick up I mean VGC is
still um talking about the current
switch they talk about the OLED to bring
the cost down to about the cartridge
slot they um you're obviously talking
about maybe again the fall second half
of uh 2024. so it it's looking like
finally it's coming you know we've got
enough sources you know and according to
Nintendo's um financials it seems clear
that it's time for um new Hardware in
2024 this is of course according to a
Tokyo based industry consultant which uh
since it was projected to switch to show
double digit declines and switch
hardware and software sales this year
after it cleared several years ago so it
had a seven year
dominant run switch was coming in super
hot but now it's time the new Switch
so where are we at with this Alex's way
so we start with solve new Switch these
are the details where we at how we
feeling Nintendo's back to take the
crown let's go yeah I mean I mean it's
about time it's finally concrete
evidence that is happening right uh it's
it's been we need something there's a
little more juice sure
um yeah I mean everything there makes
sense because Nintendo's MO is not
losing money from day one they don't
care about oh we'll lose a little bit of
money up front no we're making money day
one so it makes sense they're not gonna
give you an old ad because the old is
going to be the revision a year and a
half later
oh the hustle the hustle how they do
how they do um obviously the the
thinking is that it's they're working
with Nvidia again right so it's going to
be some sort of Tigra uh type of chip
um what I'm hearing is that it could be
in the realm of PS4 Pro in terms of
power I mean according to Bobby Yeah
well yeah
I hear extension saying that we know
what it is it's the same power of a PS4
and Xbox One yeah so and some of the
other thinking has been a little bit
more powerful maybe more like a PS4 Pro
and considering what we have out there
you know it's a possibility
um but they're gonna keep doing what
Nintendo does uh
what else when it comes to
when it comes to the fact that it's
coming out late in the year surprised me
right yeah I think they had such a
success with the game with the console
coming out uh 2017 like March right
right around tax time right around tax
time right and they said
remember and it felt like when they when
they had Mario Odyssey at the end of the
year felt like a double launch like okay
now we got more stock in we're gonna end
with this brand new game again it's like
a second goal round so I kind of felt
they were so successful with that that
they would do that again but again
Nintendo being Nintendo maybe they have
other plans right so um I'm thinking
this is gonna launch with a Mario game
right I think they see the the
importance of launching a huge game with
their consoles I don't think Metroid
Prime 4 is it Metroid Prime 4 is still
fairly Niche so people excited for it I
think Metro platform will be there kind
of launches but I do think it's a
cross-gen game
um everything else they talk about in
terms of power what it could be I
this is
because the one thing they haven't
talked about is what's the gimmick what
is the catch what is the Nintendo
gimmick right we had HD Rumble before
and and and the fact that it was
portable and dockable
what's the gimmick this time around
right and if if they're doing something
to if they're going to keep adding stuff
to the Nintendo online stuff and that's
how you're gonna do their back compat or
whatever and they haven't been able to
DS games because the screen can't do it
do they do follow their old Cadence and
be like okay the next witch has is a
clam shell the next switch can actually
give you two screens right so because I
honestly what other gimmick makes any
kind of sense at a wow somebody you know
what's funny they have tried so many
gimmicks they're out of gimmicks they're
out of gimmicks right they're out of
gimmicks there's really nothing I mean
and we say that and then they'll show us
what the gimmick is like oh yeah that's
right and you know I never thought about
that so I don't know I'm thinking I'm
thinking it could be a clam shell so
they could have a dual screen you know
the Nintendo they won't call it the DS
because it'll be the Dual switch so
maybe the switch Duo
going that bag again go in that bag the
switch to Duo I don't know because again
they gotta have a hook
Nintendo does not ever not have a hookus
since man when's the last time they
didn't have a hook yeah Super Nintendo
they always do something something yeah
yeah off the beaten pad so I'm
interested in to seeing what that is uh
the back I think the back compat is in
there I don't think there's anything to
worry about I think there's certain
features when they give people Dev kits
they purposely don't show them all the
features because they know it's gonna
leak so there's a lot of stuff that you
know about what the machine can
specifically do that I think they're
still holding close to the chest they
just get they just gave them a dev kit
that gives them the power that they have
to work with that's pretty much it I
think um I don't think they don't I
don't think these Dev Partners apart
from the closest to Partners right knows
any more details about what that machine
looks like and what specifically that
machine is capable of you know like I
said the hook of the machine so we'll
see uh hopefully we get some information
soon I don't know when they plan to talk
about it but Nintendo doesn't really
care about you know people they could be
mad that people start leaking their
information I don't I never never really
seen them rush to get ahead of it once
it starts to leak though yeah they kind
of see they stay quiet so maybe we heard
something maybe we won't maybe it's a
Keeley announcement at the end of the
year you know with the with it with the
name of it or something like that but
we'll see but I'm glad that it's finally
happening finally yeah I know after all
this time all the pros and the twos
along
new switch your people you was gonna
kill everybody for Nintendo games
remember that don't forget everybody
we're going dead because of you so I
mean technically you're gonna kill
people because I didn't want to do that
so well you're the only one on the
island that was they had a difference
okay but that question was deliberately
set for us to argue and you're upset
because we argued about that you ain't
what cop about it that's my only thing
you didn't want to even hear what the
other choices were but we gonna continue
yeah it comes the to the Virgin too I'm
kind of curious what the launch title is
going to be because Zelda already came
out maybe Metro Prime four uh maybe
maybe as my Mario game I don't know if
they would do a Metro Prime 4 for a
launch title Metro has not ever like
been known to sell well it's just been
loved a lot
wonders comes out this year so it's not
that it would be a 3D Mario right I
would guess
what
maybe you know I don't know it's just
it's interesting so how we feeling about
the um how you feel about like the the
back of Pat is up in the air the LCD
um you know like that still as opposed
to the OLED and stuff like that for what
you I don't care about the OLED LCD
thing okay
um I have the original switch and I
don't think it has an OLED screen so I'm
rocking LCD one right now as far as like
backwards compatibility it sucks that
they're not going to give us the option
to do that but Nintendo knows if they
let you buy Odyssey if they let you buy
breath of the wild and tears to the
kingdom on next-gen Hardware
neither that or they'll put them on
their uh their service their internet
service whatever it is oh we got the
password again on Nintendo online that's
what you're saying
wow we should be used to that though the
Nintendo is the company that will put a
game out for you to buy
for a time frame and then take it off
the store
so you know they are the consumer if you
looked up anti-consumer in the
dictionary a Nintendo symbol would
probably show up the size
and nobody could do this got you I mean
PlayStation could probably do this
because their their fans don't seem to
care about what they do but Xbox
definitely couldn't get away with this
it's a very interesting
so all that not an issue back a pack
most likely had the better lead
all right fan Avenue we know what the
power is and all that stuff so far kid
can't wait this is what I'm here for
do switch let's go come in here finally
get rid of that 480i crap let's get it
it's up at the 720p okay 720 900p level
let's go
I'm down with that it's better than what
we got
you can sit in and cap for something
that we we better than what we got so
I'm down with that um the the old OLED
screen I don't care about that okay uh I
think it's gonna be slightly larger I
think the hook is going to be um it's
gonna have a projection screen I don't
remember oh my God
this is now going somewhere else
you laughing but they did have a pass
that'd be crazy if he's right yeah he's
been right lately a lot yeah they did
have a a pattern before about a
projection now check this out imagine
they say the champion needed television
right and your kid can just go in this
room and project it straight on the wall
and and play the game this sounds very
Nintendo and again they they also had
you playing with cardboard yes in it
um these guys have they did AR they did
uh 3D they did all these things they're
not going back to 3D they're not going
back to AR they're not going back to
face mapping it will have cameras on it
and we'll have a projection that
projection will allow you to play the
games on the wall they're not gonna have
back compact
um
let me see this is okay no all that no
backing back projections what about that
power how are you feeling about that oh
no it's gonna be a PlayStation 4 uh Pro
type go with that you're okay with that
yeah I'm good with that yeah they're
gonna do all of that stuff but I think
the hitch the the something that they
didn't do and they put a patent in for
before and Sony put a patent in for that
too that same projection thing but I
think uh Nintendo beats them to Market
with Superior technology and it and it's
wait Nintendo beats who was Superior
technology no I'm talking about as far
as projection goes you know um oh
usually they do something and then Sony
comes right behind and like cops Oh you
mean innovate yeah innovate something
new in that well it will be a superior
technology to whatever they have
available right now in their hands right
now you know as far as that trust I
believe is going to be projection thing
I I can see them bringing people
together playing with it and you can
able to you know watch movies on the
wall in your room
a low powered uh projection from from
your uh your switch whatever is old I'm
curious how much you think this sucker
is going to cost so for projection in it
it's not gonna be a high power
projection the cardboard didn't cost as
much
um you know they it's it's they always
do something
and they do a little twist to it like a
gimmick yeah it works in 3D they said 3D
with no glasses what what everybody
laughed and they did it what if instead
of it being in the switch it's in the
dock
it could be I'm about to say like do it
would you be upset this for all y'all
would y'all be upset if they go away
from the switch form factor which you
know pull it out go go wherever where
you go I think they're going to stick
with that um I think it's going to be
you know what's sad we think we know
what switches
we have no idea what they're gonna do if
I come out right with this projection
screen that's the greatest ever oh yeah
you want to fight again but I think so I
saw something about this before so I
think that's about it Nintendo and you
know Simon you said you know going back
to number one they are number one yeah I
didn't say that what do you mean no
somebody said in the beginning like
Nintendo back to like that was you know
what I only said that because no lately
that this is finally now the year's
decline PlayStation has overtaken them
now with the mpds and stuff recently
probably not an overall sales yeah yeah
they're not they're not selling they're
not selling month to month what they
were right it's finally on a decline
right that's the whole reason they're
making another pie for it
yeah you know none of their games sell
20 million matter but um
it's going to be a projection screen
it's going to be very nice it's going to
be a good hook everybody's going to buy
it Nintendo's gonna be back it's going
to be the Darlings you're going to be
playing Donkey Kong on the wall
and you're gonna have so much fun I see
that happening that's the only Avenue
that they haven't been in they've been
in AR they've been in VR they've been in
um 3D they've been in cardboard they've
been in dual screens
so this that's in the next logical step
they did the motion controllers
next logical step well not fair enough
look this is interesting um
yeah uh as far as the I got I got to get
them a little smoke man like all right
look I want it of course I'm gonna get
it of course you know say most as long
as they don't do nothing too crazy
because Wii U I think it was we really
was two left for me it was just way too
much and I was like nah I'm not there I
knew it was hot craze with your grandma
off a little bit and bring the family
over you do the thing but I was like I
was not in even though that was a
successful system for them and then Wii
U was kind of extension and that switch
was perfect like switch is exactly when
I saw that commercial I'm like that's
gonna work the portability over here
over here why would you say whatever
it's not breaking news but the preload
for star food is going to go up on the
ninth
um
I mean it went gold so yeah that would
mean it would be going good because you
know a lot of people are concerned a lot
of people concerned
yeah but um experience has been quilled
yeah that would I would definitely
silence a lot of people that were
begging for demos let's just say that I
need a demo reload please listen to My
Demo on tonight so um yeah so like I
said with that
well I hope they they've got the formula
let's not get cute
let's not get crazy
you know what I'm saying dude you know
how they do it what's the saying snatch
what is this song snatching defeat from
the jaws of Victory yes let's just stay
this is what I was I was saying again
when I saw the switch I'm like nah y'all
got me this is what I'm talking about
but um look Bobby let's snitched this
whole thing out shout out to Bobby kotec
um put out the whole business so we know
what the power is I'm okay with that
Xbox One PlayStation 4. at least you
with a 1080p ring sometimes you get your
frames up for the most part we we
audited those and third parties should
look a little better but I got to defend
little man since nobody was defeated
little man and I it's all thanks to the
switch too because now that we know that
this joint gonna be a PS4 and an Xbox
one level hard drive according to Bobby
Bobby listened to the trial
we don't found out guess who's now
porting down to Xbox one and PlayStation
4 what are the most popular third-party
games Star Wars all of a sudden out of
nowhere like there was a demand so like
people were clamoring no Cog is going
down the record they got that damn dev
kit they know what at least the The
Avenues of what the specs are gonna be
and you best believe developers are
going to find out a way to port to that
system which is low respect in the
series as I gotta defend little man I
gotta defend them you know what I'm
saying so all this hold him back Guess
who's coming out and guess who
developers are going to be making for
that's all I'm saying so that people can
miss me with the holding back the
generation because it goes down to
lowest common denominator and it comes
down to where the install base is at and
where you can make money at and for me S
is going to be one of those things that
they anticipate to be a money maker and
switch to is gonna be one of those
things that you better but remember when
they found out a way to put Witcher 3 on
on switch then when they found out a way
to put out a world oh they was fighting
out ways sorcery was happening you ain't
hear about no memory constraints you
ain't hear about none of that you found
out the Tegra trip was Ill all of a
sudden you guys I'm curious what you
guys think the name of this of this
console going to be wow
the switch two and if it has a dual
screen it's the the switch Duo switch
Duo oh I can see a switch Duo I could
see that I could see that what you said
I don't know about it
no dual screen with just a projection
yep and they're gonna say switch Pro
the pro gonna stand for projector let's
get a recall to switch you
all they got to do is just come in a
little bit stronger and then have one
more hook to get you back again my only
thing please Nintendo no more cops in
the string can I have messaging can I
have party chat yeah yeah come on
come on man Nintendo you in there talk
to your people I'm tired of I gotta
glorify what we call it a glorified
stalkerless and nobody's talking to
nobody the biggest thing they just see
what I'm doing the biggest thing I can
see them doing is building the switch to
around Discord I can see now I see I see
them uh doing all of that stuff because
remember they want Call of Duty they
already got the 10-year contract Call of
Duty
don't remember remember that contraction
when they had us
and you got get a VPN
yo that was the worst when they had this
platoon this is how you do it attachment
yeah bro I remember when I had my my
Handler name was Sergey
said King are you ready have a dog how
bad a diagram looked like it was some
networking thing
it looked like a test with an A-Plus
like a networking test they said this is
what we needed algebra for
friendly y'all better get on them and
demand some proper oil I all I'm asking
is to send a message to my friends they
are not demanding anything over there
are the epitome
you buy or you leave
Maybe
foreign
what happens if if they they go extra
with the mobile thing it's like they
make a cell phone oh they make us go
outside and you know what they would do
that that's the sound I can't even get
laughed like they could literally do
that but they don't have the second
switch it's like a it's like a a phone
that you push a button and like the wigs
come back look Nintendo Xbox giving
y'all Call of Duty
and came down from the heavens and
blessed y'all in this deal y'all better
accommodate and have proper online play
and functionality and chat if my king
don't shake your head we got a demand
but I want change.org I want us to have
Picket Fences we gotta demand better for
Nintendo yo come on we're gonna do all
of that all right oh what happened there
there's a
an IGN article
Microsoft Engineers helping border gate
three split screen
[Music]
sits down gets his coffee his his
blueberry muffin turns on the computer
sees all this that's serious ass and
he's like put up the put up the series
that's that side man it's like a bad
signal on the air but it's just a
serious ass I know you're not talking to
me you call me
let's get up this somebody gonna get
smacked keep my car
don't let Jason Ronald come through with
the scar with the squad with the Wizards
those man can't do what little man come
with two little men
back to back he brought the major he
brought the engineering major skill in
the chat I don't know if it's true or
not that the news is months old hey hey
we gotta see we got to see I don't know
yo he acts little man yo who did it
little man hold his eye
you have that like thing in the
courtroom they're like can you point at
the person that Infinity you know that
Jiffy snitching
yo you was bothering him
if they do that makes the uh
spoiler without context is watching
right now I want you to make a meme
that's your parent kick we need that
that we need that little kid yeah the
little kid on the stair that's pointing
like this is him it was him we gotta see
if it's real it's real no doubt so look
that's what I got to say
that's all I got to say but I just
wanted to defend a little bit a little
bit because that is give me my Croc
shorty
because if I find out that switch to as
low as spec than the series s on anyway
and if it do and these games figure out
the way to come out I don't want to hit
any more this generation holding back
fear-mongering talk that I will see two
people doing it in the Mr Hartman
literally the mustard Harbor gig you
know what we're gonna have to do when
Boulder's Gate comes out on uh this Xbox
we're gonna have to play uh we're gonna
have to do a community day okay
but anyway that's what I got there we go
I'm gonna invite people to come over and
play it on the switch Co-op I mean um
[Laughter]
not happy of an OLED switch to isn't an
option once you go OLED you can't go
back Major L for Nintendo of this only
an LCD model
wait for it
it's all right they'd be like Omar
coming
oh
man thanks
all right you know then when they're
gonna be later on in the gym we're gonna
get that whole leg with the extra the
little Zelda package you know how that
go with the big release
oh yeah you know how Nintendo do yeah uh
probably kill it two dollars which had
no bad compat for switch two makes it
DOA for a lot of people it does but I I
mean again that's that's hyperbolic it's
not DOA it's just it's come outside
would be like it's exclusive that's what
they want you to think yeah but that's
why they're gonna they're gonna try to
get rid as many base switches this year
as possible 100 and make us buy all the
titles over about you virtual consoles
or or intent learn from our boy Jim Ryan
ten dollar upgrades
they do that the upgrade yeah
that would be wild
then we see Corey Tidwell five dollar
super chat if that Kaka not bad
competitive they better not call it
switch two they should call it the
switch up because they stay getting
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
back to you SOB this is good wow
wow there we have Mr mdj with the two
dollars Super Chat the gimmick is dlss
when docked uh yeah well we'll see y'all
know all right yeah we got to see
they're making 60 frames
that's your business if you go outside
you got to be here
I can see the commercials now have you
ever
I have a a migraine from watching a
PowerPoint but we got the dock 2.0 for
you they better not do that there we
have let me see we have Corey Tidwell
2000 which had already did cardboard so
maybe PVC
now we have Nintendo Super Chat they
have a patent for six axis analog looks
crazy a six axis analog oh wow oh they
go they're jumping out there they go do
it try to be too fresh and super
Innovative for no reason I like the
original switch and um the the like when
you put it together you can do
one two switch
hear that stuff man it was nice yeah
and we have Dragonheart you'll be five
dollars with that nobody ain't said
nothing to Nintendo for taking away my
Super Mario Brothers Battle Royale game
I was right about that that was my joint
what's this Mario Battle Royale oh it's
still Mario I know what you talk about
it's the the one that was online the
tetris 99 Mario 99 that it'll go
then we got Nintendo taku 10 super chat
how are we questioning Nintendo's back
compact one the Wii Wii U Game Boy Color
Game Boy Advance DS and 3DS will fully
back compact with the previous
generation when PlayStation and Xbox
weren't doing it only time back impact
didn't happen was when switching discs
to carts yeah that that that's a big
problem they got rid of the whole
Virtual Console like that was fun I
think these cartridges will be a little
bit bigger size and I don't know if
they're gonna have two cartridge Bays
inside the um the new Switch I think we
can get virtual console and play your
old games back the difference between I
think the difference between that and
now is now they're trying to build an
online infrastructure and they're using
their own games to online infrastructure
but I have online messaging and party
chat as long as I guess to me like I'm
on Discord when I do that stuff anyway
so like that stuff why are we giving
them a pack
it's not get I just don't care
it shouldn't be there I just don't
personally I'm on you because you could
you was gonna kill us for Nintendo games
and now you out here capping like it's
okay they can do this I'm bad I never
said it's okay okay all right cool we
good I said I personally don't care
because I'm always in this as long as
it's not okay that's right I don't I
don't care either
but but no but no you're right you're
right though it is it is absolutely it's
great it's disgrace
[Music]
so if tonight you get steak with beets
you eat the steak with beets
potatoes shout out to Paris he said it's
a 50 podcast sweet black he said I swear
I was here yesterday they still
shout out to bed Paris bad we got to do
bear better for Nintendo I'm trying to
start a rally I'm trying to get a
change.org going come on anyway
[Music]
you could have a billion people sign a
chain.org
they will come out on stage and rip up
the bathroom
wait here I don't see him soon
I could see as Savage as they are when
they think they're that they don't care
what about outside input they'll go up
their show called this perfect system
for all these online features and that's
what you guys want but we got something
else over here you're not gonna get that
thought it'll taco man I wanna do the
man better man it's your people so I
want to see the Super Chat for that that
online chat and messaging let's go
continue then we have a puckish rogue
100 to two dollars to chat did Dolores
talk about Killer Instinct yet yes
at the top of the show Breaking News
breaking news
then we got Dragonheart yobi once again
two dollar Super Chat it's gonna be
called Super Nintendo switch I think I
don't know that I like that
I like it I like that but then you're
gonna get into the whole conversation
about get people being confused and
I'm telling you I mean I'm telling you
what they had to do with what it is
a level then we have Robert Kelly Japan
is the key reason switch to is portable
I don't think it's the key reason they
they've realized they could not you
can't put three consoles that
essentially do the same thing on the
market one of them will die they had to
go they had to Pivot and they just pivot
at the right time and it was like you
know if you look at the Wii U the switch
is a natural progression from the Wii U
so it was just serendipitous
then we got Robert Kelly Super Chat uh
PC is the real switch Pro that's true
[Laughter]
projector Builder yeah
Activision y'all and uh Transformers
games back in the news so it all started
with an interview with um from Hasbro I
believe at Transformers world and I
guess they were talking about
um you know uh the Activision
Transformers games and you know that as
far as why they you know it won't be
happening so pretty much they were
saying that they uh thought that the
hard drives apparently Activision is not
sure what hard drives there are in the
building and they said when a company
eats a another company when a company
eats a company that eats a company
things get lost and that's very
frustrating however good friend of the
realm Lulu Chang was survey had other uh
thoughts about this and she I guess
quote tweeted this article about Hasbro
wanting to re-release old Transformers
video games but Activision lost the code
and she says the headlines are wrong
we got the codes B she should have put B
at the end
I told you it's not lost and never was
so this set off a chain reaction King
this is your topic Lulu outside with
this yeah she she even uh tweeted at me
because I quoted that she tweeted at me
um
I want those games to be uh re-released
when the APK deal is you know done I
want you know time all on one
Transformer dude and the fact that she
gave Credence to uh the reality that
they aren't lost that they are there so
it's just you know getting past one
hurdle to the next hurdle but the fact
that she can see the words out there and
say no that's false We're not gonna let
you run with that that we you know we do
have those
um it just stands to now
what's up with the licensees yeah and
stuff like that what happens there but
if those games are available excuse me I
pray Microsoft put those games out
and I think that uh people that didn't
get a chance to play those games and
they'll be able to play them we'll have
some fun playing them I thought this
topic was pretty cool and decent because
she didn't have to you know tweet and
let everybody know that now we're not
gonna run with this false narrative that
it's lost somewhere inside the building
I was lost anyway we do have them you
know it's funny she might be looking at
them for all we know
um but uh I want the games to be you
know released and I can't wait for the
ABK deal to be done and I hope Phil you
know goes in they can hammer out some
licensing agreements with Hasbro which I
want to ask you a question okay like I
don't know if you saw Christopher train
had a statement
um replying to Lulu kind of like well we
asked y'all Activision for comment
before all that about them and y'all
said no comment so don't come at you
know Hasbro like that because we asked
y'all before Asbury I wouldn't talk
about it like so
Christopher Drake said I mean I think
Christopher was in his Fields
um they tell you no comment because they
don't want to talk to something right
now because it probably has some other
things going on and just because
somebody doesn't answer you doesn't mean
the answer is no no
um good point
sometimes they can't say stuff at
certain time trial you know you got to
get out of the me me me and try to look
at it from all the way around the boards
if a company tells you no comment that
gives you the opportunity to say and you
got to be a positive person because
negativity will have you scooted oh that
means no then if you can't answer me a
positive person would say oh wow that
leaves the door open for you
um
right there you gotta stop it at the
world in a negative uh aspect and you
got to start looking at it more positive
I think that's more reflection on you
Christopher
shout out to Chris Virginia
I feel like you know but you're right
you're right definitely a way you could
look at that as opposed to a negative
thing absolutely right I gotta got it
right it tells me no comment on
something I'm not gonna take it as
negative I mean I just feel that maybe
they can't answer something right there
but I'm always going to skew to the
positive I feel that I feel that Lord
addict lord of the Transformers games
Rockstar finishing got all the
achievements
he's got all the achievements his
favorite
I'll set you up I set you up what are
you feeling man all right let me ask you
because I know you probably don't I
don't even know I know I know you know
but let me ask you a different question
how do we get from they look someone
said they lost to now we got to like do
you feel that's a little weird though
like the Hasbro someone how did Hasbro
get to that information who told Hasbro
that that that that Lulu had to come out
and correct I think that disconnect is
wow don't you think probably a middle
ground person they took contacts still
on the the team wait will you check this
out for me we lost the code
that's wild yeah I don't know I mean
miscommunication most likely or maybe
Hasbro
just assumed it yeah or maybe they just
said it to generate height to force them
to do it it clearly Hasbro wants this
because he has been want that obviously
they want it and you know Microsoft once
they buy at ABK you know I've said over
and over again they don't got Comic Book
Heroes so you know
imagine they made a triple A
Transformers game yeah I doubt it but it
it would be it would be crazy and at the
end they give you a gift code to buy the
Optimus Prime dead and the little yeah
oh man this guy
[Laughter]
wow that's what you get this guy was
wild disrespectful to my child
yo that still hurt B
um anyway
what if they had your man in a box who's
your man
[Laughter]
I was told like one of the Transformers
multiplayers like really really good so
it's just like if this is an option and
they could do it I 100 support it like I
probably won't play it'll be in Game
Pass so I might try it out you know and
I'm talking about it it's cool I think
it's fun all right we're gonna say it
was bad while disrespectful so uh this
is our heart man Transformers joints you
know yeah so what question didn't they
kind of do a re-release with these yeah
and now they missed it but they will
re-release kind of Xbox One weren't they
yeah they were down the disc you put
them in it does not pull up anything
they you cannot read yeah I literally I
have both physical disks well 360. put
them in my series they do not launch to
anything and there's no digital stuff
right they've been pulled so the license
probably has most likely expired so you
can only play it on 360.
they are literally paperweights right
now for and I remember this because I
got in trouble or LSM I took video get
them can you get the back of pack but
you know it's out and you can put the
disc nope only 360. wow but you know
that's the thing though it wasn't even
360 back compat on Xbox one because I
don't know that was ever a thing but I
thought there were some they were real
they re-released they reissued digital
versions right along with like I
remember Marvel was The Ultimate
Alliance people were complaining that
the the version sucked or whatever it
was we're not good okay because I knew
that happened and I think I got those to
be honest I saw again I guess I can't
access them so
yeah these need to come back
um these were great man these were these
were these were great and I'm it's funny
because I I love Transformers not as
much as Cog oh like I I really enjoyed
it but these games kinda
the level of detail the level of love
you know
you see what this man doing right now
look at this fooling he gonna put the
death
she want us to go away now it's over
this is wild disrespect I had to go to
Universal theme park and see this
foolishness being sold that that is talk
about how's that action figure and it's
a dead car it's a dead Arrow talk about
action figure falling leader yo enjoy
enjoy what keep gonna play with that
what where they do that at universe that
was wild disrespectful I was so mad
[Laughter]
so for me it's like yeah these need to
come back especially now I'm kind of in
a Transformers back like High Moon I'm
in a I'm in a bad compat bag I I had
forgotten to tell you guys this but I
recently purchased I recently purchased
a 360 uh actually Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 3 360 for my co-worker all right
beautiful Mint Condition console I was
like I you know I'll get my 360 back
because I was on this thing where
there's a lot of games that died on 360.
never got back compat on Xbox one so
it's like the only way to play them is
to play them on Xbox 360 right and
specifically I was looking at the
Activision games I'm like even when the
sale goes down the licenses would have
to come back right it would have to pay
for that so I got like I got uh
Wolverine the X-Men Origins Wolverine
game which is that case
yeah
imagine the Transformer game like
dominoes into another MechAssault it
could happen it could happen so these
guys when you think about um High Moon
the thing is they're still in existence
but now all they do is all they do is is
Call of Duty and this is what they do
now but they did the Deadpool game they
did the the Dark of the Moon game
the movie tie-in bag movie tie-in bag
yeah they had to do it
um but they did the Bourne Conspiracy
game which was another game that I got
for 360. I remember trying it out and I
remember I was like oh wait a minute the
hand the hand feels cool like a Bourne
movie but again back back in the day
when I I had access to every 360 game
we had folders and books of games I'm
shaking my head over here I'm shaking my
head over here because somebody did
certain things to make sure
certain things
for them things I played that is crazy I
I can't remember what came in here I
can't remember what game it was if
someone in the chat could probably uh
you know collaborate I played a Jet
League game and I can't remember oh
Jeffy it was uh for something honor
something honor yeah I can't remember
what the name was it was PlayStation
rise to honor rise to honor
yeah that was in Italian with that movie
with Aaliyah yeah it was kind of right
out in that same space right it was in
that same space his rise to honor and
then I remember playing playing
Stranglehold on the 360. with uh Italian
fat so you guys would know that if I
ever got my intro
[Laughter]
it's time I know you've been calling out
for Matt teager right and I'm like I
went online I went to LinkedIn like they
just kind of underground they kind of it
feels like they they're so heads down
into Call of Duty which sucks and let
him lose let him listen I know a lot of
you know Microsoft Executives and you
know uh activity I know there's people
who know us that know this man free Matt
T please someone find him his Twitter
has been inactive for like six years
since the last game came out I don't
know if he stuck in Call of Duty
Purgatory whatever he's doing Cog would
like to talk to him I'm speaking it into
existence I would like Matt Teague who
directed the war for Cybertron Fall of
Cybertron High Moon Studios if you know
the whereabouts of this man please we're
gonna put out a milk box with his face
that's what I've got with it I would
like him on we gotta talk to him let's
go there's a lot the studios that are
making Call of Duty that we would like
frayed from the Call of Duty hell
but I feel like it's unrealistic to
think that that oh yeah I know that I
know that it's unrealistic that's going
to happen fast right that's for sure
absolutely but Phil Dominus Maximus says
maybe maybe those surprises King he said
maybe maybe they're like yo we we gonna
let call PlayStation have this for 10
years because we ain't releasing this
every year anymore I mean it's a money
maker we'll see we'll see if they gonna
walk away from that bag yeah that's too
much back it just it just depends on how
much more money they make off a war
zones than they make off the actual 60
retail games anymore 70. yes all I would
say is Phil did say that they want to
bring old franchises and stuff back to
Activision so it's gonna be some you
know I'm saying but like that's all
that's free I just want prototype that's
what Maddie won that yes
all it said prototype was like the worst
game ever
So speaking of prototype I also picked
up because it works in back compatible
360. the Prototype the Prototype
ultimate destruction oh I hope game is
Fire King back again no we gotta stop
now why we gotta stop Why Stop Now why
are you disgusted that I'm making amends
for what I've done
we're gonna let you uh go and make do
your Penance
We're not gonna do that I was part of
the I was part of the bootlegging past
are we not gonna do that I'm the one
that's pressing the button down I just
want to get it oh okay okay
um it's on my keyboard oh that's what it
is okay so um no it's it's we ain't
gonna do that because then I then I got
to start making them in um
I'm not shaming anybody to do what I'm
doing that's just bad not that man
trying to change his life mind you mind
you some people don't have that stuff
anymore if I did I would silently
quietly be playing some people like to
be shame yeah clearly
oh yeah somebody said the old all the
old 10 shoes is Texas Activision bro oh
speaking
I ordered uh something of Darkness right
the ten two for the OG Xbox ten choose Z
on 360 I don't remember being the
greatest okay I'll get it okay it was
actually not as bad as people think it
was and it was the first Co-op attention
it was like foreplay attention but it
was actually good it was actually solid
it wasn't that bad well it wasn't the
one that was on Xbox Live arcade not
that one this one was on 360 and I
remember they debuted a new feature
remember you know they can see whatever
that was the first one you could stink
because if you went into like dirty
sewers and stuff like that right and you
hiding it as a ninja close by
the samurai I've said it a few times I
really love the way the Samurai game
you know I never got into those I never
got into the original way of the summer
I I put a lot of time Activision got
some choice but they had a lot of
Spider-Man license that a lot of comic
book games
that's the thing I want yeah I want what
you want all real Spider-Man game I want
them to work them out and I want all the
drop and one day
you know what I honestly I wanted to
drop the same day that Spider-Man 2 come
out
you know I I actually I just want the
crash games and Game Pass I don't know
why but like the fourth one I haven't
played and it was on sale for like 15
bucks the other day and I was like why
would I realistically buy this for 15.
I will say it would be a kick it addict
it would be a little messy to see crash
running around
we don't crash from outside the building
crash I don't care too much about that
you don't care about crashing I care
more
about all those old Spider-Man games no
that's a fine I know what you're doing
and a lot of people say considering
we'll never get a Spider-Man so I guess
we can start there yeah it'd be like ah
King if they whack
and I'll be like
so what
you just want to say you don't got them
that's all you want I just want to say
um I'm playing Spider-Man too
and even though I could buy it on my
PlayStation 5. if they could if somehow
in this world please God like if
somebody acted like he's not gonna pick
up Spider-Man too I already pre-ordered
it
please God like like you know you've
seen that joke when Venom was uh praying
to God please kill Peter Parker
[Laughter]
all those Spiderman on the Xbox inside
game pass the same day that Spider-Man
that is not gonna do that's the distaste
vitamins actually for for the Spider-Man
I just want to talk about it
for the Spider-Man game that week that
we talk about it I got to replace one of
these posters with a Spider-Man post oh
that'd be fun let me find like the HR
probably this Demon Slayer one right
here pretty sure it's an old Spider-Man
game like um
like like like Maximum Carnage or
something yo you know I found I found a
fable poster
it's like the original Fable but that
that sucker was like 70 bucks
I'd like it but I don't look like that
but I'll wait for the Fable the Fable
game to have a poster who was going on
because I want to get my balls off
before we finish off let's unless it
would solve you get your boxes
no that was it look bro I want this
joint to come back um this was the best
news that guy I've been speaking yeah I
know I've been speaking this game until
existence for the longest these are
these are my heart people sleep on the
multiplayer the multiplayer was highly
underrated
um also they also had a horde Mode
called escalation I believe was five
players and the multiplayer you create
your own Transformers you could do the
you know the flight the car I think
that's what people are telling me uh
multiplayer was really good really good
and then again the the voice acting the
first one I believe was a three-player
co-op game single player but the voice
acting in all the games was crazy you
had Peter Collins Optimist you had the
whole framework I think I believe it's
Megatron the whole cast The Sound way
even the Stars
close to the voices of the storyline as
original and then the second one was
ridiculous and they did my dream King
when you could come you can be a
combiner you could be Brutus and what I
liked you got that you had you played it
from the Decepticon outside and the
autobot side and it just throw those
games amazing Matt Teague I'm pointing
out somebody find them tell them Cognito
was look he needs to be in the realm uh
this is one of them bucket list for me
kind of like a jake Solomon he does I
remember when he was he's such a G1 head
and the thing about it is he debuted a
tournament they can never you would
never be able to do the dynamite it
ain't gonna work and he had gremlock and
enjoy bro did that man like uh I want
those joints to come back so yeah this
is good I think it's a good sign I think
Activision clearly I mean Hasbro clean
wants to do it
the key is if Activision want to do it
but then they own by Microsoft it's a
good time too man like that bumblebee
movie was very good and Rise of the
Beast is very good oh and you you
haven't seen it yet I still haven't seen
it I was out there at Universal I'm
seeing all this advertising everybody's
going crazy you need to see it yeah oh
you need to see it
oh that's why I see what's going on
you need to see it because what they're
doing with it oh they're doing something
okay okay they're doing something that
I'm gonna appreciate from a G1 I don't
know that you appreciate it
no no no no it's it's the closest proxy
uh approximation that we can get to the
cartoon movie oh okay okay
I think that's on Paramount it's not
easy it's already on Paramount oh we met
today
and we got that I bought that for Halo
anyway so okay that's it go uh support
that and I think it will generate
interest like you said with the movies
all that bring them back as a feeling
and then you know make a little get mad
teeth out of prison you know come on we
got free Magic hey I know it's fine look
we out super chats and then get the uh
what you call it King's ready
then 10 down deal tackle five dollars
attack while we're demanding better
PlayStation 5 Xbox should have their
digital games ten dollars off at release
No MTX in any paid first party games and
DLC in their subs he diverted answer the
question about that party chat and
messenger sir stop what about ISM I need
you to get on your Square Super Chat you
want that message into that party chat
for the day I want you to Super Chat
that
then we got Dragonheart yo over two
dollars we have better learn how to
upload them files to the cloud
welcome to the 20th century
Corey Tidwell 2000 was that Hasbro
watching kna
they lost the code
we didn't no he did oh
then we got Spartan Spartan 661 two
dollars I want a new sudeki remake from
the original Xbox I remember sudex
remember Suzuki yeah yeah then we have
puckish Rogue 100 505 super chat if XBox
renews the licenses for Transformers and
Marvel games do you do you think they
would release them on the switch or PS5
I mean Legacy Legacy they those were PS3
games as well bro the judge said she
don't really care even about Diablo I
don't think it matters the Quake thing
is rumored to be on PlayStation 2 and
they could have easily it could be
withhold that yeah we're trying to get
bread yeah no no no
one if you want to play these games
please have game pass on your console
then we have mdy five dollar Super Chat
Heads Up to Cog of Bot con the big
transformers convention is at American
dream in East Rutherford
three weeks visiting NYC that weekend
blessings yeah that's what I actually go
to that one I've been to that one that
was the one the other day I met Ron Lim
for another um
okay yeah I know about that I might
actually pull up on it I gotta tell
Marlon about that yeah that's a big one
we got KJ Wars 85 remember for two
months Lord gold thank you sir
appreciate it absolute salute put the
crust in the chat pick up for KJ Wars
85. and we're caught up nice all right
let's get out of here
he ready he did two shows that's not
that I got um Chinese food oh okay I got
you there with the switch two rumored to
be launching in 2023 which aspects of
the console has you most concerned
choices are a no back compact or the
possibility of no back of that b
Nintendo Party Chat and messaging
C LCD over OLED or D I don't care will
it hold back the series s though
please Rock the vote it'll go up later
thank y'all for rocking with us with the
streams and all I think shout out to
attic for holding me down though because
for real
it was it was crazy it's today but I
appreciate y'all and uh hiccups
I was waiting for this I was waiting for
this house
having a trash system for chat isn't
anti-consumer though
all right
King where can the people find you
getting Chinese food you can find me no
place bye Lord attic we're gonna find
people find you what you gotta go to us
sir uh you can find me on Twitter lordat
IOP you can find me on YouTube gaming
addict I'm 100 Subs away from five
thousand nice
going to be sending you after the
podcast to a review I did on a chair
amazing go watch this review it's one of
his best reviews I'm telling y'all it's
hilarious yeah you just say that because
I almost never one well let's let them
find that coming through and I hope you
guys enjoyed the review okay we're gonna
find people friends
there we go there you go everybody
um gcx fam love y'all that was super fun
super dope we will do it again and Lords
will be at Pax West we got fun stuff
playing some gas cooking but all one
sport and then we got stuff anyway we
out of here enjoy your Sunday thank you
peace
thank you
[Music]
foreign